Let's do it for
one.
Boom.
Hello Travis.
What's going on?
Thanks man.
Thanks for doing this.
Really stoked to be here.
It's cool to have you.
Hey.
So I wanted to talk about what we were
talking about right before we started.
I've always watched you play drums and
I'm like,
how the fuck does that guy's arms not
fall off?
I mean,
you,
you have so much repetitive motion.
I've never understood how you could do
that.
Just barely know.
I,
I pull this.
Pull this thing like write up like a
fist from your face.
There we go.
I always do battle ropes.
Oh,
okay.
That happened.
That must constantly.
I'll do 30 minutes.
I'm not high intensity the whole time,
but just keep my shoulders and arms
moving as I prepare for a tour.
But yeah,
I think my risk,
my risk probably have gone through the
most hell over the years.
Like I just feel like just normal
people's risk strength that probably
don't have because there's been so much
grinding,
like they pop and oh Jesus,
you all sorts of weird things.
But yeah.
But I'm still,
you know,
I feel like because I do battle ropes
and because I box and the kind of
workout fast twitch muscles,
I really don't get tired.
That's,
it's amazing because so many people have
repetitive stress injuries.
I mean even secretaries,
they get carpal tunnel,
you know,
people get who write a lot,
get carpal tunnel.
Kids are getting injuries on their
thumbs from fucking around with their
phone too much.
Yeah.
I felt like when I smoked cigarettes a
lot,
I was feeling kind of the first symptoms
of that stuff and I wasn't drinking a
lot.
I was kind of a dumpster on tour,
you know,
not really taking care of my body and I
could really feel it.
And then why are you still Vegan?
Yeah.
And you run that restaurant was
crossroads or it's one of your.
One of the owners running it is saying a
lot.
I couldn't do that.
I shouldn't have said running.
No towel towel.
Ronan is the man.
He's like the Las Vegan chef ever.
And he's like an old punk rock hardcore
guy.
Like knew John Joseph.
John Joseph keeps trying to get me to go
there and I almost went last time he was
in town with them.
Next time I'm going to make it down
there.
I think probably 80,
90 percent of the people that eat there
aren't vegan because it's that good.
Yeah,
that's what I hear.
Dana White said that.
Yeah,
I.
Dana.
We usually have dinner there when he's
in town,
so I think for Dana to be able to sit
through it and enjoy it and Matt Serra,
I think he brought everyone for like,
I don't know if it was like fight
companion.
It was like one of those was.
Yeah,
it was Dana White's looking for a fight.
Youtube show.
Yeah,
I was on tour but they facetime me from
there,
but yeah,
towel is a like a GE.
He's the best Vegan chef in the world by
far.
That's cool.
How did you get involved with that?
Is it what you.
Were you already,
you're cleaning your diet up because of
your,
your injuries or because you were trying
to keep your body tuned for drumming or
you just wanted to clean it up?
Period.
Now?
I was vegetarian since I was 13.
Really?
Yeah.
And then,
uh,
after my accident I was in the hospital.
Actually long story,
I'll just sum
up into real plain piece.
Yeah.
And I had to eat meat in the hospital
because they didn't have any other kind
of Vegan options,
a protein,
Saudi bags of beef Jerky,
whatever.
They would give me whatever I could
stomach and not like kind of like think
about what I was eating because I wasn't
eating at all and I was just ditching my
food,
given it to my friends because I didn't
want to eat any of it and I got caught
so long story short,
a little bit of meat and in the hospital
and when I got out I just felt like the
next evolution of my eating would,
would try and be Vegan and it was so
easy in la because we have so many great
vegan restaurants.
So yeah,
that was,
that was pretty much it.
I was already Vegan.
I was actually at a bad brain show,
one of the best hardcore bands in the
world to ever,
ever do it.
And tell approached me.
They're saying,
hey,
I had this idea for a restaurant I'd
really like to beat you,
know,
you to be involved.
And I said,
say no more,
just tell me what you need.
Because I do think before of a weird
thing to approach someone with a man
thinking about open up a restaurant.
Yeah,
I need this drummer.
right.
No,
I think he was just reaching out to
friends and family because he was,
he was oprah's chef and he was ellen
degeneres chef and he was all these
like,
you know,
really high profile people is Vegan chef
when they would,
you know,
do a Vegan diet for however long.
Some,
some forever,
some just like a two week thing.
But uh,
I think he just got to the point where
he wants to do something for himself.
And then crossroads was born and I knew
how good he was.
So I just told him,
say no more,
tell me what you need from me and I'm
there.
And then it just,
you know,
I think it's been five years now.
Well it's got a fantastic reputation.
I know a bunch of people that have eaten
there and they love it.
Well it's not because of me,
it's because of talent is food for sure.
Yeah.
Talents.
Scott,
the Sh,
the chefs that are just,
you know,
the best know how hands on were you in
the,
were you just one of the people
promoting it?
Like how hands on were you with the
construction of it or nothing with like
the decor or anything.
He would run stuff by us like hey check
this out,
tell us what you guys think of this.
As you know there's basically menus
change every season so it's not the same
menu all year long.
So as we prepare for the next season's
menu,
he's like testing it on us,
the,
you know,
the season prior.
So he'll be bringing out dishes and,
and letting us try it.
But yeah,
he curates the whole thing.
That's interesting.
So when he gets his food,
when he's preparing his food,
is he getting his stuff directly from
farmers?
Like how,
how is he getting his food?
Yeah,
directly from farms.
Yeah.
So he has to curate these relationships
with these farmers and just like go
visit them and find out how they're
growing their food.
Yeah.
And,
and you know,
you'll be all set with a menu if it's
fall,
but then those same vegetables aren't in
season so he has to rethink everything
for the next season and not kinda repeat
himself.
So he really,
he's really got it down to a science.
And how long has he been Vegan for?
I don't know how long.
Tasmin Vegan.
I've never really asked because it's got
to be incredibly difficult to be a Vegan
chef.
I would imagine being a regular chef was
difficult.
But when you put all those restrictions,
you know,
and just have to make things taste
interesting and different and yeah,
I think that's where chef Scott comes in
because he's actually comes from a meat
background.
So he was working at Italian restaurants
in Italian,
Mediterranean restaurants that cooked
everything.
So it was infusing this Vegan obviously
like lifestyle of eating with,
you know,
chef Scott's tastes as well,
so I think he had to think that out to
where it would appeal in and mediators
would eat there too and not really
notice a difference because I agree,
you know,
sometimes I'll be on tour and you go to
a Vegan spot and I'll take my bus driver
ran or my,
whoever's traveling at me and they're
like,
oh man,
this is rough.
You know,
like they can't stand it.
Crossroads is not one of those spots
where you're thinking about like,
man,
I might not enjoy this meal.
There's some good spots in la.
Has some great spots you ever go to
follow your heart in the valley all the
time.
Great spot.
Yeah.
That's the spot.
Close to home that I love.
Like follow your heart.
A shout out to Erewhon.
Erewhon has like good vegan options.
A Chef Ito who has a spot in downtown
called Allach who took a vow of silence
22 years ago.
Yeah.
Well a special man.
Twenty two years ago took a Valla
silence.
And these done.
No more talking.
What in the fuck is that about?
Yeah.
So he just communicates if,
if he has a lot to say or write it down,
but you just read the lips and I know
what he's saying.
But he,
he shows up to.
Oh,
that's so crazy.
Yeah.
He takes a lot of photos so he'll show
up to like punk or rap,
whatever,
whatever show I'm playing.
He's in the pit with this camera,
this silent guy who doesn't say a word
and it's his cooking is phenomenal.
So.
But yeah,
La,
we're spoiled with great.
Great being in restaurants.
That's a fucking trip.
Twenty two years of no talking.
Yeah.
He also does like this juicing where
this year he juiced for 189 days with no
food.
Wow.
What did we get down to?
I think he was.
Yeah,
he lost about 20 something pounds.
Fuck yeah,
he does it every year.
Wow.
Yeah.
He's trying to vanish,
right?
Let's try to not talk.
I don't think I could do it.
Intermittent fasting is like as much as
I can do.
Yeah,
I do that every night,
but that's the vowel sciences frequently
that silence is freaking me out.
Yeah.
He and I,
I've never really pried and kind of like
asked a bunch of questions.
Why?
Because they even have to write a lot.
Yeah,
that too,
but no,
I've been around when people ask him,
he just said he wanted a time out for 22
years.
Yeah,
that's a serious fucking time.
I don't know how old his homeboy.
He's got to be probably in his fifties,
so almost half his life.
Yeah,
what the fuck man.
But he spends Christmas with me,
spend Thanksgiving with my family and I.
Oh,
that's cool.
Everybody just smiles at them.
Yeah,
everyone just smiles and waves.
Basically.
He'd be a good guy to sit next to
someone who's on coke.
Totally.
They would just talk his ear off.
He just be sitting there all silent
night,
blah,
blah.
Fuck man.
That is.
I've never even heard of anything like
that.
Does he make any noises?
You Whistle?
No.
I've heard him snort one time when he
was laughing so hard,
but that was about as close as it gets,
so he doesn't laugh out loud like,
ha ha,
wow.
Nothing terrible comedy club audience
member.
Yeah,
it would be rough.
He has a march to.
It's called March of silence.
That happens once a year where you have
a bunch of them that basically,
you know,
that are basically marching for the
march of silence for like the cruelty of
animals and whatever else.
So I like to have him on the podcast to
see how long you talked to them for.
Yeah,
just to see what,
what it would be like.
That's so strange.
It sounds cool.
I love that there's people like that out
there though.
I do.
I love hearing those stories like the
world needs him.
You know,
like when you said that I got excited
and the guy has been salvatore.
I'm like,
Whoa,
you know,
there's something about that.
It makes you go wow.
I was talking Hella loud when I first
met him and he was like,
I can hear you,
you know,
because it was trying to wrap my head
around,
you know,
no one did an introduction going,
hey,
this guy's silent.
Oh,
they didn't tell you?
No,
I had no idea.
So I'm talking really loud and he like,
he like just whispers to me like mouse
to me.
I can hear you.
And I was like,
okay.
Then I just figured out over time.
Wow.
Silent by choice.
Who?
Yeah,
that's heavy.
What is he involved?
Like heavy meditation or Buddhism or
anything very strange like that?
Yeah,
he meditates.
I think he has like a lot of kind of
Buddhist,
a kind of qualities like kind of.
I think he,
if he had to lean in some kind of
religion or practice,
it would be that.
Wow.
Yeah,
that's intense.
That's a serious commitment,
man.
I couldn't even imagine going 22 days
without talking a day I think.
Any,
any,
anything?
I think we'd catch ourselves.
It being very hard.
I was going to get my tonsils and
adenoids removed because I have sleep
apnea because I have a fat neck.
But uh,
I found a mouthpiece that I couldn't
sleep with that keeps my tongue from
falling over because I have a.
When when your neck is thick,
your wind hole is smaller believer,
not because the more muscle you put it
in the small year your whole gets.
And then if you have a big tongue when
you lay back,
you can actually block your airway.
Wow.
Yeah.
And so friends that I know have had
their adenoids,
their tonsils removed,
and they actually take some of the soft
tissue out of your,
your passageway so you can breathe
easier.
But the problem is you can't talk for
like seven days.
Oh yeah.
That would probably be real for.
You may wonder if wide neck,
you know,
like the,
the,
the Internet phenomenon has the same
problem.
I get like I must sleep terrible.
Yeah.
His neck starts up here.
It's crazy.
As next starts at the top of his ears
and works its way to his shoulders.
Tonsils out is a,
uh,
it's a bum out.
I did that.
Did you,
did you have taught politeness or
now you knew what I had is I had,
I was smoking tons of weed.
Right.
But I would smoke backwards,
like I love the woods.
So yeah,
everything is right here.
I got them right here.
Yeah.
So I'd smoke about 20,
20 backwards a day.
Yeah.
And I was recording an album with the
transplants and I turned to skinhead rob
and I was like,
Yo,
I think I think I have something like
something's lodged in my throat,
like I could barely breathe right now.
And um,
kept smoking,
didn't even,
you know,
didn't I didn't really know what was
going on.
And then I went to the hospital that
night and they rushed me to another
hospital to get my tonsils removed
because they were like twice the size of
they should be.
And then I had a throat infection and
then it comes to find out I had what's
called the bear to soft goods,
which is like precancer lining my
esophagus from smoking and I don't know,
I guess just abuse over the years.
So that was,
that's what led to my tonsils being
pulled out.
These are serious,
like when you think about this,
like you probably shouldn't smoke too
many of those because it's just plain
tobacco.
I love,
I love them though.
It got to the point where I couldn't
smoke joints.
I couldn't smoke out of a bong a pipe.
It had to be a backward.
That's where I am.
Yeah,
that's part of it.
I like them.
Did you ever smoke cigarettes?
No.
Cio date.
I smoked a lot of cigarettes and then I
quit smoking cigarettes.
Just smoked weed and then I discovered
backwoods and I was kinda getting a
little bit of both.
Still getting the tobacco that I missed.
Um,
but yeah,
yeah.
My friend already said that he started
smoking spliffs in England,
you know,
and when he was over in the UK,
the next,
the weed with tobacco and he got totally
hooked on tobacco again because he had
quit cigarettes for years and then he
started smoking the weed mixed with
tobacco and before he knew it he was
smoking cigarettes again.
Yeah.
So he smoked while he was over there and
then he quit soon as he was done.
And then came back to you.
US?
Yeah.
I feel like they just started smoking.
Just pure weed over there,
Jeffrey bearish for years.
It was both.
Yeah.
I don't understand that.
Like,
how'd that,
how'd that work out over there?
Yeah.
So illegal over there too.
It's like Jesus fucking Christ.
It's 2019 fellows times when I used to
fly over there we'd have to take tons of
wheat to our nuts just,
just to be able to.
And in our road cases just so we could
smoke over there because they had dirt,
weed,
you know,
it was horrible.
We'd.
But yeah,
it was a pain in the ass.
It's fucking dangerous bringing that
stuff overseas though.
If you get arrested.
That's.
That's serious.
Yeah.
I brought it aside.
Bring it everywhere like that.
And we went to tape a gaff tape.
Jesus man,
like you teared up the first layer of
your nuts off when you go to grab your
weed.
But yeah,
we would do that.
And then it's a commitment though.
Yeah,
I actually brought it.
I made the big mistake of not bringing a
bunch,
but I got to Iraq.
We went to Iraq for like right when the
war broke out.
What was it?
Like 2003 or 2004 and we were over there
and,
and a scandalous Esteban oil,
the photographer,
he's over there with us documenting the
whole thing and I pull it out because
we're at this airport and ball rain,
but I feel like it's a field and no
one's going to mess with us.
And he's like,
hey bro,
look,
look at,
look at the back of your fucking
passport.
Look what it says.
And it says right there,
like,
you're basically like they'll kill you
if they,
if they find,
you know.
You brought any drugs and direct or you
know where we were a ball rain,
so I did away with everything and I just
kind of took up drinking
and I'm not really much of a drinker but
do you still smoke weed?
I don't know.
I have a friend who's like a dear friend
is like a cool,
like young doctor named Dr B in San
Diego and I called them.
He actually removed my,
my tonsils and then like a week later I
found out I had what was called
precancer Barrett's esophagus.
I said,
what does this mean Dr [inaudible]
should I just like,
Kinda like,
Kinda like toned down like how much I'm
smoking?
And he's like,
no,
this means this is your warning shot.
Like pay attention,
stop smoking esophageal cancers.
A rough one to killed Christopher
hitchins.
Really?
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a rough one.
That kills a lot of fucking people.
Once you get it and you're gone,
I think it kills.
Like think hitch said like 95 percent of
the people get it now.
Yeah.
So I felt like he,
he's always pretty honest with me and I
just stopped.
Like I love CBD.
That's pretty much what I mess with now.
But that's all.
Do you find a lot of people use cbd and
they fund that?
It alleviates anxiety and let them sleep
better.
Do you find that?
Yeah,
as long as I take like triple or
quadruple the amount that it says to
take on the bottle because I feel like
what I take,
if I take what the proper dosages,
it doesn't do much,
but I'm one of those people whose minds
racing constantly.
I'll get home from the studio at one or
two and I'm just like kind of like
figuring out how long I got to sleep
before I get to wake up my kids and go
to school and I just sat there with my
wheels spinning and less.
I use cbd and then that kind of helps.
And then I had.
I have what's called trigeminal
neuralgia.
Have you ever heard of that?
No.
Oh,
it's the fucking worst.
It's called the suicide disease because
basically all of your nerves in your
face or firing all at the same time,
so it almost feels like what you feel
when you think you need a root canal or
you have like a tooth that's messed up,
but I got trigeminal Neuralgia and I've
only had four episodes,
but when I do get it,
I use cbd and it.
It's been amazing,
but if you look it up,
a lot of people go actually go to a
dentist,
get a bunch of root canals done that
they don't need or they don't know how
to treat it,
and usually people kill themselves.
Whoa.
Yeah.
It's gnarly.
I didn't really know about it.
I just was home with Dan.
I was like,
what the fuck?
Like my face is burning.
It's miserable
pain condition that affects the
trigeminal nerve,
which carries a sensation for your face
to your brain.
If you have trigeminal Neuralgia,
even mild stimulation of your face,
such as from brushing your teeth or
putting on makeup may trigger a jolt of
excruciating pain.
Holy Shit Man.
What is the cause?
What causes that?
All different things they thought like
mine,
I maybe got mind from impact,
like from my accident and then maybe
little sparring that I've done has,
has triggered it.
Also dental,
when I get dental work done,
it triggers it so.
But the CBD stops it cbd in it.
If it's really bad,
there's um,
this medication called Gabba Pinton.
Uh,
and I feel like that's been a real great
way to kind of mask the pain.
And what once the Gabapentin calms the
nerves kind of duds the nerve.
Twenty four,
48 hours it's gone.
If it's a really bad episode of it's not
so bad,
it just keeps it away.
Well,
they see that a lot of nerve diseases
are inflammation caused.
So sometimes like if you change your
diet,
you can,
you can smooth some of those out,
like lower the sugar intake and some of
the other things that might be causing
inflammation.
Did they give you any advice like that
now,
but around the same time I figured out I
was allergic to gluten,
which I really thought was horse shit,
whatever.
I was like,
yeah,
right,
okay.
Yeah,
we need to be gluten free.
Um,
then I tried it and the doctor I had
seen said,
well you really got to try it though.
You got to commit 100 percent,
you got to give it at least like two to
three weeks and see how you feel.
And I did it and it was a game changer.
Like I felt normal.
Whereas I'd have a lot of ups and downs
depending on what I was eating and I'm
still eating clean at the time I was
still eating Vegan,
I'm eating,
you know,
whatever.
But a lot of a lot of us can't digest
or,
or kind of our bodies can absorb the
gluten.
Yeah,
well it's.
Have you ever had pasta in Europe?
It's very different.
Oh yeah.
So much shit in ours,
you know,
so much.
Well it's the Maynard Maynard Keenan
from tool.
He explained it to you because you know
he runs in Austria in Arizona.
I didn't know that.
Yeah,
he's,
he's the guy's a fucking wizard man.
He's got his own winery runs in Austria,
but he said that when we subsequently
looked it up after he told me this in
the,
uh,
early turn of the century when they were
growing wheat,
they experimented and change the wheat
to make it more dense so that you could
get more yield out of an acre.
And so by doing that they changed what,
how your body processes it and is more
complex gluten's in like a stock of
wheat,
like an old old timey wheat like you
would get like in Italy or France or
something like that.
It's a different wheat.
It looks different.
It's a much more scrawny looking plant.
And so if they had an acre that you
don't get nearly as much wheat.
And so in America we said,
well,
boogers boater and we made it bigger and
better and thicker and your body has a
much harder time processing it.
And that's why people get so much
inflammation and leaky gut and all these
different ailments that people get from
bread and pasta in this country.
It's because of this much more complex.
We.
But I buy pasta overseas.
I buy this,
I'm God dammit.
I'll say the name of it.
It's I,
I found out about it in Italy that they
sell it in America.
Just for that reason.
Yeah,
because I can eat it and if I want
pasta,
it's not that disgusting.
I'm fine.
I love Pasta.
I do too,
but it's just,
it's something that I've found if I eat
a lot of it just fucks me so I have to
make sure that I don't.
Let me find it real quick and I'll pull
up the name of it and I felt like leaky
gut,
it was like a hoax.
I was like,
what are you talking about?
I've never even heard about this,
but I feel like it's legit and they're
spot on about that.
It's called Morelli,
Morelli Spaghetti and it's from Italy
and the type of wheat that they use,
it's a very different type of wheat I
get.
It tastes different.
It doesn't blow you up as much.
It's A.
I think somebody explained it to me like
what kind of wheat you're looking for,
but what I found is that I've tried the
gluten free pasta and it's like,
you know what I like better than gluten
free pasta,
Spaghetti squash,
spaghetti squash with Marinara sauce.
It's fucking delicious.
And I actually sometimes like it better
than pasta,
but um,
they sell that at Erewhon all the time
in the hot part.
It's spaghetti squash is outstanding.
Yeah.
And it's guilt free,
you know,
you can eat it.
You,
you're not thinking you're bloating
yourself up.
Yeah.
But we've ruined pasta.
We ruined ruined pot.
But you know,
it gives you that feeling,
you know,
that feeling you get after you eat a lot
of it,
like,
oh,
that's what that is.
Or your body's like,
what the fuck am I doing with this?
Yeah,
you're immediately tired loaded.
But if you eat an Italy,
you don't get that feeling and you look
at those people over there,
they're not fat.
It's weird.
It's true.
Yeah.
They're walking around all over the
place and they're eating pasta and
Europe.
Everyone's walking or riding bikes.
Yeah.
Americans.
Well,
that's the thing about France to France,
when they're eating those baguettes,
they're,
they're eating it with this very rich
butter that's like a grass fed butter.
It's a dark yellow butter,
so it's very high fat content.
It's got a lot of essential fatty acids
in it just you're just getting in.
It's a different kind of bread to and
meanwhile they're not fat and they're
drinking one and they're not fat.
Like it doesn't make any sense.
Yeah,
agreed.
Standard American Diet.
It's just fucked up,
but I've always wanted to ask you that
about like the drumming because I mean
everything that I do
like everything repetitive,
whether it's boxing or even archery.
A lot of people get injuries and archery
just from repetitive stress from just
pulling the bow back over and over
again.
I'm like,
God Damn Travis,
this,
your whole fucking thing is repetitive.
It's like I see you every time I see
like my,
my shoulders hurt,
my elbows hurt.
Now I'm in my first week hurts.
My first week sucks.
Like on tour,
really like getting acclimated because
even practice rehearsals are not a show.
It's just a different intensity.
But,
but yeah,
as long as I trained for it,
I'm cool,
I kinda like boxing has helped so much
and I don't box because I think I'm a
tough guy or I think I can beat people's
asses or whatever.
It's really just for functionality,
like so I can play the drums the way I
want to say.
And I started doing it for that reason.
Well No,
I started when I knew my son was being
born,
like when my girlfriend at the time was
pregnant,
I woke up that morning,
I ran to the freeway and back like twice
and then I wouldn't found a boxing gym.
I walked into 10 goose.
I actually walked into John Prays who
used to be Tyson sparring partner,
um,
and it was like 2005 to 2003.
And then I started boxing.
I just walked into 10 goose and I,
I started jump roping and hitting pads
and I don't know,
I just had this urge to want to like box
and be better.
That's so interesting.
Like just knowing that you were going to
be a dad,
I just wanted it to be better.
I wanted like,
immediately I just thought to myself I
wanted a lifestyle change,
I needed to evolve and I needed to know
how to protect this little human I was
bringing into the world and I knew I
needed to change my lifestyle because I
was
kind of out of control.
Wow.
It's an amazing thing that happens to
you when you become a father.
It's a weird switch that goes off in
your brain that you can't really
describe to people that don't have kids.
Yeah.
And it's even weirder when the switch
doesn't go off.
So like,
you know,
you see people who are horrible father's
parents and I just don't get like,
how didn't,
how did that switch turned on for you?
You know,
how like the ones who don't want to be
around the kids freaked me out the most.
Yeah.
They just don't want to be.
They just want to be away all the time.
I just,
I don't get it.
I don't know why.
Yeah,
I couldn't imagine.
But yeah.
And now I love boxing.
Like it's one of my favorite things to
do.
I've been doing Muay Thai a little bit
more because I can kind of save my hands
because it's not good on my hands in any
way,
shape,
perform.
How so?
Just the impact over and over.
Do you feel professionally wrapped?
You get umbrella correctly,
but it still bothers my knuckles hurt.
Really?
Yeah.
Are you using big heavy gloves?
What a one ounce gloves are you using?
I think there are 14 ounce.
Maybe she'd switch to like 18 or 20.
Yeah.
Get a thicker padding in the front.
It'll protect your knuckles better and
it even gives you a better workout
really because you're pushing more
weight.
A little heavier.
Yeah.
Pushing more weight and you'll have
more,
more impact.
But another thing I would say is,
um,
get a bag.
That's a water bag.
Water bags are fantastic.
Have you ever seen those before?
I've seen him at the gym.
You get awesome fucking dig into those
things and it's,
it's minimal impact,
but you still pushing the same amount of
weight,
you know,
through throwing the punches.
You can still explode at the same amount
of force,
but you know,
you're sinking into that bag.
And so a lot of people with tendinitis
find that that's a way better option is
another.
Um,
uh,
I have two bags out there.
One of them's a fair tax bag and fair
texts makes it's a Moitai bag,
but it's softer.
And the other one's a monster bag.
The monster bags are really hard,
dense,
dense as fuck.
So I like the combination of the two,
but the fair one is good.
If I'm injured,
if like my shoulder's bothering me or
something like that,
I can dig into that bag and it's not
going to have the same jolt is hitting
something solid and hard.
So if you're having problems with your
hands,
that's what I would say.
Another thing you can do is they make
wraps that are gel wraps.
You slide them on your hand,
almost like a glove.
Yeah,
that's what he just told me about as I
trained with.
Yeah,
those are great.
Yeah.
And then that on top of the heavier
glove,
I bet it'll stop all the hand stuff.
Yeah.
I'm going to try that.
Yeah,
he just told me about that.
That'll protect my knuckles a little bit
more because I find if I lift weights I
never get big.
Like I never look big,
but I feel kind of stiff and just slow.
It's the worst feeling ever and I did it
one time right before tour I had,
I was living in Cheviot hills for a
little while and I was working out at a
gym over there and it was all
bodybuilder guys and I would train with
one just to like be pushed and I got
behind my kit and it was the worst
feeling ever.
The worst.
I felt like it was in slow motion,
so I figured out like I need to train
how I want to move when I'm actually
playing the drums.
Weightlifting is fine,
but you have to do it lightly.
The thing about weightlifting is people
want to do it to failure all the time.
You know,
do 10 sets of this and five sets of that
and go to failure every time.
Come on,
push,
push.
Don't do that.
You shouldn't do that.
I subscribed to the Pavel Tat Salini
method.
He's a famous Russian Kettlebell
instructor and his philosophy is that
you should do more sets but less
repetition.
So like say if you could do a weight and
you could lift it 10 times,
don't lift at 10 times lived at five.
He lifted 10 bucks going on my voice.
All this talk about esophageal cancer.
My Voice is rebelling,
but if you say if you could lift
something 10 times,
lifted five times and just do more sets
and give yourself a lot of time in
between sets because if you're training
for strength,
you can do certain things like
kettlebells and specific where it's
strength but it's also endurance.
But really if you just want to do
strength,
the best way to do it is to do a short
set of a few repetitions and then do
multiple versions of that.
Like take a long time off like five,
10 minutes and then do another five
reps,
five,
10 minutes,
do another five reps and then do it
again in a couple of days and then do it
again instead of like once a week where
you just blow your body out and then
you're like,
ah.
That feeling where you can barely move.
That's terrible.
It's not a smart way because you don't
recover as well.
Yeah.
And you ended up getting hurt or having
to take a day off.
You know,
what I started doing was with this one
trainer named Don,
we figured out kind of like a metronome
workout.
So you're actually like a tempo workout
where you're training to a tempo so you
have to do high reps,
like you know,
you'll stay to a minute and maybe the
tempo is like,
you know what I mean?
So whatever.
Even if it's quick and you're not doing
everything like exactly technique wise,
really slow and you know,
it's,
it's kind of like making sure you stay
up with the tempo,
which I feel like really helped me with
staying quick and fast with drums and
more endurance,
you know?
Yeah.
That makes sense.
Like his drumming a young man's game.
I mean,
is it like athletics where as you get
older,
drummer slowdown?
I don't know.
I haven't.
I played just as wild as I did back in
the day.
And how old,
you know,
43.
You look great.
Thank you.
Don't look 43.
Yeah.
Max Weinberg told me one time he was,
he watched me play and he was like at a
show or blink played and he's like,
I don't know how much longer you can
play.
Like that real hard dude.
He's like,
you're going to need back surgery.
You play like you rabies.
Just smashing the fucking drums.
So knock on wood,
nothing has changed and I've just a play
exactly how I always have,
you know.
Um,
I don't even want to think about a day
where I have to play any different.
Sure.
It'll come.
But do you get massages?
Yes.
That'll help.
Yeah.
Massages,
epson salt baths.
That's where the tank comes in.
Play,
man.
That thing looks amazing.
The tank is all epsom salts.
Look at you dude.
You're fucking crazy
when you watch that.
I watch you play.
And I would just go,
how the fuck is this guy?
Maintain this pace because everybody
drums differently.
You know?
I mean,
it's really interesting to watch
people's different.
Especially my friend bill burr really
got into drumming and uh,
you know,
he's,
he's really into it and I like watching
them play and it's,
it's interesting to see someone take
something up and get better and take
lessons and learn it.
But the thing that really strikes me is
how many repetitions are involved.
Like as you're doing this,
like the,
the amount of times you're hitting these
drums is fucking insanity.
You got to pace yourself.
If it's a two hour set,
I know like,
oh,
this is a verse of the song.
I can kind of.
This is not a big,
big part,
you know,
you can kind of show,
but it's like around,
you know,
if you're doing around,
look up at the clock and you realize,
Oh wow,
I still have two minutes left,
we'll pace yourself and you know what I
mean?
Yeah.
That's kind of how I approached shows,
but.
But the goal is to train so much before
you even get on tour that you're not
even having to think about that.
You're just playing the show exactly how
you want to play.
It's almost,
I imagine it's like that with fighting
where you envision what you want to do
in your head and you're in the shape and
you know the technique to execute.
You don't have to think about our like,
oh,
I can't do that.
I'm not.
I didn't practice that enough.
I'd like to be able to just do whatever
I'm feeling and not be like,
Oh shit,
I don't know how to do that or I'm going
to get tired if I do that.
I don't want that to happen.
You know?
So that's the goal.
It's just being able to execute what you
have.
The idea in your head won't musicians
have to have discipline because you have
to practice.
It's one of the things that makes you
guys so unique in the entertainment
world.
It's like,
I mean,
I guess maybe actress have to practice
standup comedians.
We only practice in front of an
audience,
but you guys have to fucking practice.
We don't go through your show before you
go out.
Now I write,
I write and I listened to recordings of
old sets,
but I don't like to sit in front of a
mirror goal.
Hey folks.
Yeah,
don't do that.
I don't know anybody because it would
feel so weird when you go up to do it.
It would feel rehearsed,
right?
Yeah.
That's the last thing you want.
You got to be in the moment.
Same thing happens with a.
If you practice too much as a band and
the ego,
try to play those songs and act like
you're having fun.
That happens.
So I try to practice a lot on my own and
I'm not even practicing those songs.
Just kind of just drill.
You know,
like Sam Kinison used to have a joke
about the beach boys about,
uh,
they're,
they're going out there playing a wish.
They could all be California girls
again,
like Jesus fucking Christ.
Whereas like it becomes a job that you
don't want,
that you want it to be fresh and
exciting and you want it to be something
that you're really in the moment and
really thinking about.
So I make up new shit on the spot too.
That's the best is I just make up new
fills or just try to reinvent the songs
to the point where even like Marco
looked back at me and be like,
whatever,
like that's the best,
you know,
just kind of freaking it on the fly and
even to the crowd it's like,
whoa.
That's cool.
You haven't heard that before.
So that's like after two or three months
of being on tour,
you do stuff like that.
Yeah.
When you get off tour,
do you consciously give yourself arrest?
No,
I'm busier at home than I am on tour on
tour.
So lavish man like you have,
you have someone saying,
I mean you do have people kind of
waiting on you hand and foot somewhat,
you know,
like a catering,
ready if you want to eat or hey you got
to go do an interview 30 minutes before
you go onstage,
a cars outside waiting for you after the
show,
taking you to the hotel.
So that doesn't happen at home and at
home I do so many other things besides
playing the band.
Like I produced a bunch of rap artists.
Um,
I have crossroads,
I've clothing companies,
I have three kids.
It's way busier at home.
Tourists,
tourists.
A vacation.
That's interesting.
Yeah,
for me.
Wow.
Because I don't know how to say no
either.
Mind you,
I have a lot of things I love that I
love doing so I can't complain and be
like,
Oh I hate going to the steer.
I hate doing this.
I love it all.
I just kind of love it all so much that
I have trouble saying no sometimes.
So when you,
you're,
you said you're managing or you're
producing rap artists?
Yeah.
How many?
I'm like,
I'm in the,
I'm in the studio right now with this
group called suicide boys who are
awesome.
They're from New Orleans and we have a
eap coming out that's called a live fast
die whenever and we just finished over
the weekend,
so,
or yesterday.
So it's,
you know,
you go in there at noon and you leave
there at four in the morning every day
until you're finished because they're
only in town for a little while.
So yeah,
it takes a little bit.
Um,
and then like I worked on xxx
temptations album,
uh,
before he passed away,
I work with like smoke per,
I'm Vic Mensa,
a bunch of different artists.
Do you like sap because it's a different
genre,
helps you mix it up a little bit.
You're just a big rap fan is why
obviously you're wearing an ice cube.
Sure.
Yeah.
I grew up,
I actually listened to rap music before.
This isn't any kind of music at all,
like beastie boys and run DMC and public
enemy in the far side and Krs one.
That's what I grew up on.
And then I discovered I loved metal too.
I'd love to slayer and king diamond and
then then I discovered a band called
minor threat and the descendants and
black flag and bad brains and I just
liked it all.
And then my dad listened to jazz music
and country rebel music,
so I was born in,
raised on like Johnny Cash and buckles
and everything so and I kinda learned to
love it all and I had people around me
when I was young when I was first
learning how to read music that just
kept embedding in my head like you got
to listen to everything catches me,
can just learn one thing.
So I was actually taught how to play
traditional jazz when I was really young
and then I taught myself how to play
everything else.
That's fucking cool.
Yeah.
But that's always loved everything.
That's nice.
You have an appreciation for all those
different genres too.
Yeah.
It'd be like if all you did was UFC
commentating,
you'd be like,
I'm going to go crazy.
Like this must be so much fun for you
and all of your other endeavors.
Like same thing,
like if I was only making,
you know,
punk rock records or pop punk records or
whatever it was,
I think I would go insane and it's been
like that for,
for years,
you know?
Yeah.
I think different people.
I think some people,
if they're just doing like baseball
commentary or something like that,
they're fucking happy as shit.
They love it.
They just want to do that.
But there's some people like you or
maybe like me that they need different
things.
Yeah,
I will go crazy.
I love like studio life is awesome.
Like I did a Hans Zimmer thing and the
other week and then the next day I'm in
with a band called nothing.
Nowhere doing something completely
different.
This week I'm doing a little peep and
xxx remix it's,
it has to be like that for me are I get
really bored.
I just don't feel creative,
so kind of like,
I don't know.
That's cool though.
I like that.
How does that work?
Like you get a phone call or someone
texts you,
hey travis,
we need you to come in here and light
this motherfucker on fire and you get in
there and
yeah,
it's been like that,
you know,
or like,
some projects manifested to like there's
this band called the fever three,
three,
three that I produce and write with and
they just got nominated for a grammy
like throughout,
for a grammy for best rock performance
and that was something I just envisioned
with the singer of that band,
Jason and we started literally a year
ago and they're nominated for a grammy.
Wow.
So like stuff like that,
like kind of being an architecture
without building buildings,
being architecture and music or whatever
it is.
Whatever it is you're passionate about.
That excites me is building sounds like
there's nothing
and working with different genres to has
got to be exciting too because you can
mix it up and yeah.
Wow.
Now when you're like,
what,
when,
how do use,
how like schedule your time in terms of
like how much time you're going to spend
on your own studio work.
How much time are you going to spend on
other people's stuff?
Do you just play it by ear?
It seems like with the guy like you,
you must get so many requests and you
said you have a hard time saying no,
I would imagine it's fucking
overwhelming.
Yeah.
Well my kids come first before
everything.
Anything,
you know,
and then I get a lot of opportunities.
Like my son Landon is a big rap fan.
Like he loves her.
He was raised on rap music,
like he grew up touring with me and
little lane when I told a little lane
and he loves being in the studio so
he'll come with me to the studio so I
can Kinda like double dip work at the
same time as he's in be making music in
my studio b,
which is really,
really awesome.
And then same with Alabama.
She's,
I'm lucky they're both musicians because
Alabama and,
and both loved music.
So they like going on tour with me.
They like me.
Yeah.
Or,
or I probably wouldn't be working so
much dads.
Cool.
Yeah.
What the fuck is it like going on tour
with Little Wayne?
It was so awesome.
I came up with a rap,
a rap project where I produced.
I've made all the beats and I just got
all my favorite rappers,
everyone from like Rizza from the Wu
Tang clan to little wayne,
a game,
swizz beats.
Um,
it was,
it was crazy.
I think I had 30 guests on there and
Wayne asked me to go out on tour with
him.
So me and mix master Mike from the
beasties were like the opening act on
that tour.
And Drake was out there.
Nicki Minaj and Rick Ross.
Wow.
Fun.
So I loaded up the bus with everyone.
I brought yellow.
We'll foul.
I brought j rock a bought Paul Wall.
I brought the cool kids and we'd just
gotten a bus when we went on tour.
Jesus.
Yeah.
How long are those shows?
All those people.
How long has that show?
That's like a wall with all the acts.
At least four hours.
That's a long time.
But it's so fucking shows
like,
good Lord,
that audience must be beaten a coma.
Oh
yeah.
But then the headliners on who they are
really there to see.
But that,
that was a big accomplishment,
just being able to play in that genre of
music because I listened to it as a kid.
There's never really been a home for
live drummer in a wrap scenario right
now.
So from the beginning,
I think,
I don't even know what year it was when
puff call me when I had just joined
blinking.
He's like,
y'all want you to be in this video?
I was like,
what?
Like,
you know what I mean?
Because I've pretty much was.
I was just like,
wow,
I'm,
I'm in,
what are the biggest bands in the world?
I'm so stoked.
I couldn't ask for anything more.
And I always want to go.
I always wanted to get something.
That tour was so fun.
But yeah,
once puff asked me to be in a video is
kind of like a,
it just snowballed from there.
You just got into that world.
Yeah.
And I,
I had no idea why he wanted me,
you know,
but I was just like,
wow,
this is so cool.
Because I grew up on Biggie,
like I loved all that genre of music,
but I was okay with just staying in my
lane as well,
but when I got accepted with open arms
and I was invited to do like bet awards
with Tbi or Tiger Wayne and it was just
insane,
you know,
playing the grammy's.
The funny thing is I've never played.
The grammy's will blink,
but I played the grammys with black pit
bull drake.
Eminem.
Like,
it's so weird.
It's so weird to me.
I just feel it's a trip.
The opportunities I've had outside of
rock music has been such blessings to
you when you say all those things and
you know that you did all these things
is it almost seems like you're living in
a dream.
Yeah,
I feel like smacking myself.
It doesn't feel real when people go
like,
Oh,
who would you like to collaborate with?
I feel like I'm so spoiled and I've been
so blessed to play with all these
musicians.
I love that.
I just say nobody,
you know,
whatever comes.
I'm happy with.
Wow.
Yeah.
Well that's cool though.
That's great,
man.
That's means you're fulfilled,
you know,
you're,
you're doing what you want to do.
Like you're ready.
Totally.
Whoever.
Let's do it.
Yeah.
If you wanted to make a record,
John,
be there.
You know what I mean?
That's what I'm saying.
Well,
lucky for you,
I'm totally talentless in the music
department,
so it's not going to happen.
But you're such a talent man.
I love like when you and Dominic Cruz
are commentating together,
doesn't get any better.
Yeah.
I love dom.
He's awesome man.
He beat the shit out of me a couple
times.
Why did you let him?
Because he,
you know,
we,
we used to sponsor him a little bit like
famous,
like know he used to walk out and famous
stuff like when UFC wasn't,
they didn't have reebok gear.
Um,
and he would come down and train because
I would train with this one guy josh
over here in Woodland Hills and he said,
travel,
I'm going to be in town.
I'm going to come train with you.
And I was like,
okay,
cool.
Little did I know it'd be dom tossing me
around and like,
oh my gosh,
man.
It was so difficult,
but you roll with them.
Well now it'd be.
He'd be like,
try to sleep me.
I try to knock me out,
Jay,
so I'm giving my all and just using his
defense and you know,
when you,
when you actually swinging
in the air and you're not landing it
actually more tiresome new when you're
hitting somebody.
So I'm swinging in the air,
he's like on the side of me all of a
sudden like,
you know,
he's so quick like footwork and then I'm
wrestled to the ground and it's just a
wrap every time and he's so,
so talented.
So yes,
I love that guy.
Yeah.
He just has the most ridiculous
footwork.
His footwork is so unique to him,
to everything he does.
He's got like this weird herky jerky
little.
Yeah,
he does.
He's probably one of the most unique mma
fighters ever.
I feel like a lot of people have kind of
borrowed from his style for sure.
Yeah,
for sure.
Not to say they didn't make it their
own,
but I feel like dom was the first one
you saw,
you know,
kind of move.
Unquestionably.
Yeah.
And that's because of his intelligence,
because he doesn't like getting hit.
He's like,
okay,
I gotta figure out a way to not get hit
so much.
Like what's the best way to knock it
hit.
And it just just came up with.
It's very unorthodox way of moving.
He's a real encyclopedia of information
when you start talking to them about
fighting.
Like he's a really enjoyed doing
commentary with him because he's so
insightful.
He's so good at pointing out little
areas where he thinks people are making
mistakes or how to capitalize on certain
things that people are doing.
Yeah.
I've watched fights with him before and
he's.
And he,
he gives a different insight than what
I'm seeing.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
he's great.
Especially when it comes to wrestling
clinch work and you know,
and even like weird striking techniques.
I mean he's just,
he's so good at befuddling people that
he fights with with movement and
information like he's given them looks
and,
and they're,
they're trying to set up,
you know,
they're standing there trying to set up
and they don't know what the fuck he's
doing.
Then they have to reset.
And they try and again,
then he's given them a different look
and standing over here and then he's in
front of with his hands down and he's
not.
And Yeah.
Yeah.
That's a trip.
He's great.
Just fucked up his shoulder again man.
I know man.
I think he,
he trained so much.
I feel like he just,
you know,
he's a snap session.
Yeah,
he's a savage.
I mean he,
he got back from knee surgery and he
went so hard that he gave himself
plantar fasciitis,
say fucked up the bottom of his feet
from running and sprinting and doing all
kinds of crazy shit to get in shape.
And you know,
he got over that and I mean he's had so
many different surgeries.
Nice.
Are miserable.
Have you had that?
No,
I've never had planner.
Oh Man.
I had it on a tour where I would,
I,
I'd get these.
I get these weird kind of things where I
have to do a certain thing before I go
on stage.
So one of the things I did on a tour
that was,
I don't know,
it was about a four month tour,
is run four to five miles before the
show and by the,
by the middle of that tour I had
actually given myself a stress fracture
in my foot.
It was terrible.
Did you run on concrete?
Not a treadmill.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
Damn.
Well sometimes.
Sometimes when,
when there was no treadmill,
I'd just run out in the street,
but I kind of get like that where I just
like,
I don't know,
I get obsessive about stuff and I want
to,
I want to do it.
I get to kind of throw myself all the
way in.
Like what kind of running shoes do you
run?
Do you run with house
running?
Like honestly,
on that tour sometimes I'd running vans,
which is probably half of my problem,
but you know,
it'd be so quick like,
oh I have an hour here to do this.
But yeah,
that wasn't fun though.
It was painful.
Yeah.
When you have overused injuries,
those are some of the hardest.
Especially your feet.
There's some of the hardest to recover
from because you have to walk.
It's not like if you hurt your elbow,
you could just not use it for a while
and it will eventually heal up,
but you need to use your feet.
Yeah.
Planners,
a rough one,
man.
I know a lot of people that have got
that.
I've been very lucky.
I came from a martial arts background,
a lot of kicking and stuff like that,
so my feet are pretty strong from
moving,
but I found that a running with minimal
issues on hills that that made him even
stronger.
Yoga,
Like what?
Those weird kind of a.
What do they call vibram?
Five finger shoes.
I wear those and where there's another
company called Vivo barefoot or wear
those.
I like those a little bit better for
running on the hills because I'm running
on a lot of rocks and shit and the
vibrams they.
They would be great if everything was
soft dirt,
but I'm running on weird jagged rocks
and shit and it just.
It hurts your feet.
You've got to be real careful where you
place your feet.
Yeah,
but it just forces your feet to work as
they're supposed to as opposed to like a
big cushiony running shoe.
You know,
like cushiony running shoe feels good.
It feels good to run on it because you
get all this cushion.
It's not so jarring,
but your body really,
really should run.
I think personally,
unless you're a runner,
he should probably run less with a
minimal issue then you should run
because it's more comfortable to run
with the big fat cushion.
I think you ultimately give yourself
probably more injuries that way.
Yeah,
but you can get injuries from those
minimal issues too if you don't pay
close attention.
He tried too hard,
too quick.
Your foot's not conditioned for it.
My feet are terrible too,
man.
I had what was called a lis franc
fracture.
What have you heard of that?
It's basically your,
your foot breaks in half,
like all your,
all your tendons,
your ligaments and your bones.
How the fuck did you do that?
So I was high as a kite and it was in
Australia and I was running to the bus
and I had like two huge bags that were
like,
probably like I probably had 40 pounds
on my back and I was just trying to get
to the bus to get to the next show or
whatever and it was the stupidest thing
ever,
but it was a little like,
you know,
the little cracks in the sidewalk where
it's up higher and I didn't see and I
fell with all that weight on me and I'm
in the bus and I'm starting to think,
wow,
this is really bad in my tour managers.
Like Amen.
Just get the blood flow and try walking
on it and I'm trying to just suck it up
and I'm walking in the airport.
I'm like,
almost like tearing,
like I'm fucking hurting so bad.
I was like,
man,
I think I need to get an x ray or like
an MRI.
This isn't good.
So I play like the next two shows with
my other foot.
I get an x ray.
They said I've broken my foot and half I
need surgery.
So I,
um,
I think I ended up doing a couple of
weeks of the tour,
which I shouldn't have,
I should have gone and that surgery,
but I played it with my other foot and
then I got home,
I did the surgery and I was like six
months on crutches and just recovering.
It was terrible.
Six months on crutches and then I feel
like I wasn't feeling that great because
I was taking so many painkillers and
everything.
It was slowing down the process,
which I don't know if you've heard of,
but that it really,
like my bones became super brittle from
pink from painkillers,
painkillers,
norcos.
Yeah.
But I would imagine the pain must've
been fucking excruciating.
Snapping your foot and half.
Oh,
it was so painful when it first
happened.
It's something else for pain medication
after you got off of that stuff and just
smoked weed.
Yeah.
Is that enough?
I'm pretty good with pain.
It doesn't really bug me.
What about edibles?
Haven't really done it.
You don't fuck with edibles,
really?
I haven't had anything for 10 years.
Nothing,
nothing.
Zero,
no alcohol,
no weed?
No,
nothing.
Damn yeah,
10 years,
which was a big,
well after my accident as well,
I was fed,
you know,
four months in a hospital being fed
morphine every day for four months and
then being on all these bipolar meds and
everything else,
I honestly didn't want to put anything
in my body when I got out.
I didn't even take painkillers when I
got home.
Now.
What kind of bipolar meds they put you
on to it?
I don't even remember.
I was on like four or five.
Just bipolar and they,
I mean I had like,
I had so many,
I probably had like 12 medications I got
sent home with and I did it for about a
week or two and then I wouldn't see my
doctor.
I had actually overheard one of my
friends talking who was like a brother
to me and I had heard him talking to
someone else and he was like,
Yo,
like travis seems a little different,
you know,
it seems a little bit slow or something.
And,
and I had overheard him.
He didn't know I overheard him,
but I was these meds.
I had been telling my doctor,
I was like,
I just don't feel like me.
I feel,
I don't know,
I feel weird and I just don't feel like
myself.
So I just flushed them down the toilet
one day and the next week I came back to
see him and he's like,
how are you doing?
I said,
good.
I'm off all those meds you told me I'd
be on for the rest of my life.
They're like,
oh dude,
from what you've been through,
like you,
it's okay to be on something like that.
And I was like,
yeah,
I'm doing fine though.
Like I don't need those,
you know,
these,
I wanted to put you on a.
because of the plane crash.
Yeah.
They like,
don't shame yourself by,
by giving yourself a hard time that you
have to take these pills.
And I said,
well,
you know,
I honestly,
I don't feel like they're doing what
they're supposed to for me and actually
having a negative effect on me,
so I don't,
I really don't want to take them.
You know?
They also told me I'd never run again,
I'd never do this.
I never do that again.
So I think I just got to the point where
I was like,
let me see how many things I can prove
otherwise that they've told me,
you know,
once I stopped taking the pills,
Jesus.
So they put you on bipolar medication
because of a traumatic crash?
Yeah,
that seems odd to me.
I mean,
I'm not a doctor
obviously,
but.
Well I was kinda crazy,
you know,
I was suicidal when I was in the
hospital.
Um,
I was on so many drugs I couldn't even,
I didn't even know my friends had passed
away.
I didn't even know the two pilots had
passed away.
I didn't remember anything.
I kept thinking like everyone was in the
hospital,
including the two pilots,
including my two best friends and am.
I thought everyone was just in different
rooms until about two weeks before I
left.
And then I went crazy.
Then it was like they had a 50 1:50
cases on their hands,
you know,
I wasn't,
I wasn't in a good place.
So yeah.
Then I did,
I did a lot of like posttraumatic like
therapy when I was in the hospital to
kind of like calm things down.
Um,
once I got through all my surgeries and
then yeah,
I mean over time it was,
it was cool,
but it was never cool but I started to
feel better,
you know?
Um,
but yeah,
I think it was cause I was so crazy at
the time,
but that's,
it's interesting
that I would think that bipolar
medication would be something that you
would give someone who has like a,
a condition that just is sort of pre
predisposed to it.
Yeah.
I don't know anything about bipolar,
but I would think that that's something
that you just have to have a mental
condition.
I wouldn't think that it would be
something that they would give you to
overcome a traumatic incident.
Yeah,
I think they were afraid I was going to
be,
I had like a mental condition after
everything happened.
You know,
they think like maybe because you're an
artist that you're probably a little
crazy anyway.
Possibly.
Yeah.
I mean I think.
But I was a mess too.
Like,
you know,
like I had done,
I'd smoke so much weed,
you know,
every day and I'd taken so many pills
and I would self medicate quite a bit
that I woke up probably out of 11 and my
30 surgeries I had in the burn center,
I woke up swinging on doctors so I would
wake up and I would just,
I'd be opened up and I would just go
crazy.
Jesus Christ.
So trying to get off the table.
Yeah,
we would just try to get off the table.
I don't even think I really knew what
was going on.
I just wasn't,
they couldn't give me enough medication
and knocked me out because I had been
self medicating for so long and abusing
meds for so long.
Wow.
So you would get up from anesthesia,
you would just wake up in the middle of
anesthesia.
So yeah,
that was crying.
That was a problem.
Um,
how did you clean up?
I think after,
I think the last time I swung under a
doctor,
they were kinda like,
you,
you're not going to,
you can't be here no more.
And then I was like,
wow,
well I need x amount of more surgeries
and I,
I really was just in fighting demons,
you know,
I just figured out like my two best
friends had passed away and the pilots
had passed away and I was just like in
an ugly place.
And um,
you know,
my,
my kids couldn't visit me because 65
percent of my body was burnt so I
couldn't be around people.
So I was just in it man.
And then,
um,
and then I just,
I don't know,
I turned a corner and then I was like a
team player and I don't think I was on
as many meds.
Most of my surgeries were over and just
learning how to walk again.
Um,
being able to take a shower by myself
again,
all that stuff,
man.
I think that was just,
those are the good points that helped me
turn the corner and I dunno,
I just had more strength,
you know?
Yeah.
So wow.
So you just just turned a corner in your
mind and just sort of accepted it and.
Yeah.
Same with drugs,
like I didn't ever do rehab or anything.
I think it was mainly my kids and just a
second life,
a second chance at life was enough for
me.
I was like,
I don't,
I never want to do any of that stuff
again,
you know?
That's cool.
So once you get a certain amount of
distance between you and those days,
does it seem like it wasn't even real?
That's wasn't you doing those things?
Yeah.
You look back and you're just like,
fuck,
like I still talk to those doctors to
this day like Dr Grossman.
He's,
he's,
he's so awesome.
And he basically saved my life,
you know?
Um,
but I still talked to him.
He lives out here in the valley and he
has Grossman burn center and I go with
at Christmas and see burn burn victims
that are over there in the,
in the burn center and help out any way
I can be.
Yeah,
he's great.
it's really cool.
Yeah.
Um,
many of my friends that I know that I
had real bad drug problems and then now
are off drugs.
They look back and go,
what the fuck was I doing?
Like how did I do?
How was that me?
Yeah.
It's interesting how that happens in
your life,
who you have these new chapters in your
life and in.
Sometimes it could just be something
that happened like two weeks ago and
you're like,
who the fuck was that guy two weeks ago?
I'm not even here anymore.
You know,
like you get sometimes people make these
abrupt turns and their life and then
they go,
yeah,
I'm never going back.
And you go,
well we'll see.
And then you look 10 years later,
like,
wow,
you were right.
You never went back.
Yeah.
And I think like,
I still have.
Have you ever heard of what's called
like user dreams?
No.
Where like,
I think I fucked up and I was smoking
weed again and I wake up and I'm like,
oh my God,
how am I going to stop?
Because I love,
I love smoking so much.
You know,
or whatever your vice was,
you know,
if it was like whatever was just like,
you wake up and you think you're doing
it again.
And then you realize nom I'm all good.
I used to have dreams like that where I
had to go back to high school.
Really?
I used to have dreams for years.
Man,
you hate high school
too.
I don't think anyone likes it unless
you're like,
you know,
soon to be a professor.
Fucking doctors.
Well I just had no idea what I wanted to
do for a living and I was just like,
being trapped in a classroom constantly
was excruciating.
I must have had.
I mean I probably do have some crazy
form of add.
I don't know.
I've never been diagnosed that been to a
shrink.
But if I did I,
I mean I'm sure they'd probably try to
put me on if I tried to tell them what's
going on in my head all the time,
they'd be like,
Jesus,
sit down,
hold on.
I take these,
take these.
Whatever you do is bad.
But when I was in high school,
I fucking hated it and I barely got by.
And then when I got out of high school,
I would have these dreams where I'd wake
up in the middle of the night and I
didn't have enough credits to graduate
and have to go back.
Then it was sitting there in my bed
before I woke up trying to decide
whether or not I was just going to
fucking drop out and not graduate from
high school,
not have a high school diploma or go
back and do another fucking year of
hell.
And it was my,
my guts would turn and I'd wake up and
Oh my God,
I graduated.
Yeah.
It was the worst.
I was the same way,
man.
I just like,
just barely got by high school.
Did you go to school out here?
Well I grew up in like Fontana,
Riverside,
yet Kentucky.
Shout out to double dose.
More tie out there.
So people like to fight in Fontana.
People like to fight everywhere
now they're fighting every or play
football in Fontana.
Yeah.
Yep.
But uh,
yeah,
it was the same way.
Just just skated by high school.
And then I remember I didn't even want
to walk.
I fucking hated it so much.
I actually rode my skateboard with my
friends that were like much older than
me.
Daddy go skateboarding with every day
and we were skateboarding by the high
school is everyone walked and got their
diploma.
Just.
Did you get your diploma?
That?
Yeah,
they sent it to me,
but I didn't want to fucking be there.
Go to my graduation.
I'm like,
I'm gone.
This is.
Once I got through it,
I'm like,
you don't have me anymore.
I can be free.
It took me a while to figure out what
the fuck to do next.
Yeah.
I would sit there and they will be like,
so what do you want to do?
Like counselors?
And I was like,
I just want to play drums in a band
really?
And they'd be like,
well that's not an option.
Are you going to talk to me?
Like I was like,
just insane.
Isn't that crazy?
There's so many bands and there's so
many drummers.
Why is that not an option?
Yeah.
It'd be better if they just said,
well,
you know,
like I don't know if they motivated you
to actually do what you're passionate
about instead of just being,
well,
well that's not gonna happen,
so what do you want to do?
Fucking people that probably wanted to
be drummers and just never got a push
and never,
never,
never made it through.
But then there's the other argument that
if you really want it,
you'll find a.
yeah,
you got to do it.
I mean,
my dad used to tell me the same thing.
He'd be like,
you gotta have a plan B,
and I'd be like,
well,
if I have a plan B,
I'm not going to try that hard.
Yeah.
I started thinking in my head and then
that's when I just said,
Nah,
fuck that.
I'm,
it's only this,
no matter if I'm rich or poor,
whatever,
whatever the circumstances,
this is what I'm doing.
Like I don't give a fuck what the
outcome is.
I think that's the right mindset.
I don't think people get by that.
When I was just starting to do standup,
there was a lot of guys who had full
time jobs and they got degrees and you
know,
they would work their full time job and
then they would just do standup at a
couple of nights a week.
They never made it.
It was the obsessed guys and women,
the people that were just like,
I,
this is my fucking life.
This is what I do.
I'm going to do this.
Those are the ones that do it,
that no safety net people and the ones
that made it.
Yeah,
I mean it's going to fucking happen.
You just have to.
You have to stick with it.
I feel like the people who really stick
with it and give it like 110 percent,
your time will come.
It will,
however big or small it is,
something will happen,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
If you figure it out and keep improving
and keep learning and learn from your
mistakes and learn from your setbacks
and keep trying to push and get better
and improve.
If you do all those things is as
hopeless and helpless as it seems.
If you continue to improve,
you've got to get to a better place,
you got to get better and one day you'll
be undeniable.
And if you don't,
and if you just fall back on that safety
net,
you're always gonna wonder.
You're always going to look at Travis
Barker going fucking hand on the drums
going,
shit.
That could have been me,
dude.
I almost did it.
I actually,
at one point in my pops,
my pops is awesome.
But um,
he's a Vietnam vet and wrote him a
Harley his whole life and he just
basically said to me,
he's like,
Yo,
you gotta eat,
they gotta start paying rent at the
house because,
you know,
you're not in high school anymore or a
and get like a 60 hour a week job,
like a real job or you need to go,
you know,
go fucking play drums but you're not
going to do it here in my garage.
So I was like,
okay.
And it was probably the best thing that
was ever said to me,
you know,
as harsh as it was or whatever.
And then I had actually caved in and I
just told my,
my friend Nola was like,
you know what,
I think I'm just gonna I'm going to get
this fucking job because I just somehow
got a job that made,
you know,
in a warehouse it was like target
warehouse making pretty good money
compared to what I was making at the
time.
And um,
and he hit me the next day and he's
like,
I think you're making a big mistake.
I think you're very fucking talented and
I think you'll regret this and you can
get this bullshit job any anytime down
the line,
come live with me,
you know,
stay at my house.
You could sleep on the floor,
the couch and let's play in this fucking
band and do it.
And I did it,
you know,
I was like a trash man in Laguna beach.
Lived in like this studio apartment with
a couple of the guys and just fucking
took off.
Like I had to like,
I mean it was like humility too,
you know,
that was like playing bar after bar and
but I was eating,
I was eating,
I was,
you know,
I was skateboarding every day and I was
living at the beach,
playing in a band with my friend.
So for me I had already made it.
Those are the best stories,
the best stories.
And I think back even to this day,
I go to Laguna sometimes I'm like,
wow,
that was kind of one of the best moments
of my life besides my children being
born like poor,
no money but like happy as fuck,
like can't even think of another time.
I was that happy you.
Yeah.
Cool.
Well the only pressure is the pressure
of trying to succeed.
There's not the pressure of already
succeeding and the overwhelming pressure
that you must experience now.
Yeah.
Those are great stories,
man.
The stories of like where you didn't
know if it was going to work.
Yeah.
You figured it out.
I'm clue
those stories right now.
Some kids are listening to those stories
right now.
Listening to you say this and they're
like,
fuck man,
I'm going to do it.
I'm going to go for it.
Like who knows how many rock stars
you're making right now just saying
this.
Yeah.
Because a lot of them are teeter
tottering.
Yeah.
I'm not going to do it.
Am I not going to do it even though,
I mean I was at the time now and you
just have to,
you know,
don't worry about being cool or being
fucking rich or having money.
Just be passionate about what you're
passionate about and fucking dedicated
100 percent,
you know?
Yeah.
There's those moments,
man,
when you first starting out anything
where it's not sure,
it's not a,
it's not a definite thing.
You were in this weird limbo space like,
man,
am I going to be a loser my whole life?
Like what's going to happen to me and
those moments,
man,
when you look back and you realize you
could acquit,
but you kept going,
you figured it out,
you sucked it up.
You worked your way through it,
you improved.
He kept moving.
Yep.
Yeah.
That's life,
man.
That's what defines you,
ma'am.
Yeah,
it really does.
I just love those fucking stories.
I can never get enough of them and the
dirty,
grimy and then finally make it story
fast.
Did you run out of space to Tattoo?
I'm going to tell you right now,
I'm actually getting tattoos on top of
the tattoos.
That's outrageous.
I just got this lj for xxx.
I'm going to get working on some new
ones.
Have decided just to go back in
it Kinda like remix in them at this
point,
you know,
like getting tattoos,
tattoos.
Have you ever gotten lasered?
Yeah,
once I had like a new wife and I
divorced my ex wife and she wasn't
really stoked on the ex wife's name on
me.
Yeah,
this sounds like a problem.
So I lasered it because it was right on
my neck and she always had to see it,
but that's the only time I've ever done
it.
I,
there's nothing on me.
I really want to get rid of her.
I'm like,
oh that.
It's all a story.
To me.
It all tells a story.
It's like a moment in time and I got it
for a reason,
but I was trying to be cool and you know
what I mean?
Trying to be respectful and make her
happy at the time.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
I mean it was amazing.
She hung in there all the way to being
married with another chick's name on
your neck.
Yeah,
that's true woman.
True.
But in that regard.
Yeah.
But yeah,
I love tattoos,
man.
They're addicting because I love them
too.
Once I figured out they didn't hurt at
the age of 15,
it was on.
I didn't know.
Like people tell you,
they're like,
oh,
it's so painful.
And then you get when you're like,
wait a minute,
it's not so bad.
This is like,
it's Kinda like a,
a slight burn.
Yeah.
It's like
kind of therapeutic to bed.
I fell asleep.
I was getting same.
Same when I did my back piece,
I fell asleep and I had two artists
working on me at the same time.
Oh Wow.
Just because I fucking hate wasting
time.
So they.
Yeah,
they did my back together.
They did my head together to either
heads.
Impressive.
Let me see the head.
Let me see what that looks like.
When did you get that done?
I did my head like,
I don't know,
six years ago.
Wow.
Yeah.
I started.
I had like a piece on the side of my
that Mr. Cartoon did back back in the
day.
I love that guys work.
Yeah.
Cartoon is such,
he's amazing legend.
He's got great shit.
He's,
he is a legend.
He's a legend.
Even outside of tattooing,
like lowrider culture.
He's,
he's one of the illest.
But um,
yeah,
he,
he did that and then that kind of set it
off.
I always had like praying hands on the
side of my head and then I shaved my
head and I've never grown my hair out
since because I'm like,
fuck it.
It's permanent haircut.
No,
but what is up there?
It's hard to see what the shine I have
like Virgin Mary,
right?
Oh Wow.
Um,
I think I have like a rose.
You think
a lot of tattoos on my head.
I have like a transplant gas masks on
the back of my head.
I have one life,
one chance.
Um,
yeah.
And then like some writing.
Wow.
Now when you got burned,
did it affect your tattoos?
Did you have to tattoo over it?
Yeah.
So I lost.
I lost all of my tattoos on my legs.
Wow.
Yes.
I lost,
I lost my first tattoo ever,
which was a dag nasty.
Tattoos is hardcore band punk band that
I loved forever in a bones tattoo,
which was my nickname growing up.
Um,
but I lost everything on my legs.
So then they do like,
they do what's called that grafting.
So they.
Oh.
And I lost some tattoos from my back so
they take,
it's like a cheese grater and they grade
all of your skin off your back and my
thighs and then they staple it to you
with pig cadaver and they will wait for,
uh,
for you to start healing.
Um,
so yeah.
So I lost a lot of tattoos and then I,
I did like on my thighs.
You can't really see.
I did,
I did memorials for,
for though Chris Chain,
a Dj am who,
uh,
who all passed away in the accident.
So I put them on my legs over the graph
so you can't really see it.
But yeah,
I mean I got out pretty well man.
Like I mean you can kind of see it on my
hand,
my hand.
You can see it's discolored and stuff.
But for having almost 70 percent of my
body burnt,
like you can't really tell.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
Really tell it all because you're so
tattooed up that up.
The pain of healing burns is supposed to
be excruciating.
It's the fucking worst thing ever.
Well for,
for me to.
I mean,
I don't think you guys ever think about
being burnt.
I know I didn't.
I would just be like,
I don't know,
I just never think about fire until
you're on fire.
And then you're like,
oh shit.
And then.
And then
the,
you know,
the treatments afterwards to like do
everything,
you know,
like,
like they would put me in this big pan
that was literally about as big as this
table with different people all around
you.
And they would scrape all my brain with
a metal brush to get rid of all the
infection because I had,
I basically when I,
when I jumped through the emergency
exit,
when I open the emergency exit,
before the plane blew up,
I was in such a hurry to get out of the
plane and exit the plane.
I jumped right into the jet,
which is full of fuel.
So my whole body lit up,
you know,
so I had jet fuel just in my whole body,
like I burped jet fuel for almost three
months.
So they had like that was the main thing
to get rid of the infection is they
scrub you with a metal brush to get rid
of all of it and all of the dead skin.
And then.
And then I did about 30 surgeries to
repair everything,
like skin graft surgeries.
They saved my foot because at one point
they were going to amputate my right
foot.
Yeah.
It was wild.
I would picture strategy burnt that they
have to amputate my right foot.
Almost didn't make it.
Was it because of the way it was,
was it was necrosis or like what was
going on that they were going to
amputate it?
I think because that was the thing that
was most soaked was,
was my shoes and socks.
I jumped into the jets,
you know,
and I had done,
I had exited the plane,
I started running,
I started like ripping off my clothes,
just that's what my instinct told me.
Just get rid of everything.
But little did I know I would still be
on fire because the jet fuel was soaked
in it.
So I'm actually running towards a
highway highways right on the side of me
and I just hear some guy yelled,
like,
stop,
drop and roll.
And it just like I heard it out of all
this chaos of every sirens and
everything and I stopped dropping
enrolled.
And the only thing that was still on
fire was my feet in,
am came in,
um,
patted them out.
So I think they were on fire the longest
two.
So still like my,
I think my right foot is probably like
over 50 percent of it's a graft.
Wow.
Yeah,
it's wild,
but um,
yeah,
that was like,
I never,
like I said,
I never even thought about.
It's not something you think about until
it happens to you,
but being burnt is like,
uh,
it's,
it's horrific.
You know.
Were you affected by the recent fires
out here?
It came about a couple hundred yards
from one of my houses.
Oh Wow.
But I was in Vegas.
I was actually playing a show.
We left that morning and then we got
phone calls saying you got to evacuate,
but we were already gone with you.
Thank God.
Yeah.
Had the kids,
my dogs with me.
Um,
my,
my housekeeper was at the house so she
was able to get the rest of our dogs out
and um,
yeah,
we were,
as long as I had them there with me and
I was like,
everything else is replaceable.
It's whatever.
Um,
but yeah,
that was sketchy.
I mean,
you saw,
obviously you live very close to it.
Yeah,
we got evacuated.
Um,
while we ourselves,
before they had a mandatory at two in
the morning,
I came back from the comedy store.
My wife and I were looking out the
window in the flames are coming over the
hill and I said,
no one's going to save us.
Here I go,
we have to figure out what the fuck
we're going to do.
And she's like,
I think we should go.
And I said,
alright,
I think you're right.
And we just got a hotel room and we just
bailed and I just grabbed.
I literally grabbed my laptop and I
think that's it.
Some,
some clothes and then the kids were a
little freaked out.
But I said,
look,
we'll just look.
We're here.
We're all right.
Like we could buy more shit.
Like the dog's fine.
We're fine.
That's how I was too.
I was like,
let it burn.
Yeah.
You know,
I don't want it to burn obviously,
but rather than you being hurt,
like,
fuck man,
this is,
this is.
It's an inconvenience when when you're,
when you lose your house,
it's a horrific tragedy when you lose
your life,
you know,
we're not,
we're going to get the fuck outta here.
And so they were freaked out.
But within a day or two,
I mean we stayed in a hotel for a week,
but within a day or two they were.
They were cool.
We were laughing about it.
Same.
We did the same thing that came,
came home but did not really home at a
hotel for a week.
But yeah,
you felt kind of helpless,
like you couldn't do much,
you know,
it's not like I could sit there and and
put out the fire myself,
you know,
they wouldn't even let us in our
community.
Yeah.
Same here.
Crazy for people that weren't around
here.
They don't know how crazy it was.
But the sky was filled with smoke
everywhere you looked with smoke.
I mean all of La was filled with smoke.
It was,
I've never,
we were.
We stayed in Beverly Hills at the
Waldorf and you look out the balcony
window and it's just fucking gray.
Just smoke everywhere.
I've never seen fires like that before.
Never in my life
neither.
And I always see we're on high alert.
Do you not see it?
Like my kids are at school over in
Malibu or really close to there and I
always see high alert but nothing's ever
really happened.
You know,
there's been small fires,
but that was horrific.
That was just,
it looked like Hiroshima in our
neighborhood.
Like you know,
airplanes flying really low,
dropping fire retardant and it was,
it was crazy.
Bill burr flies helicopters.
He's got his helicopter license and we
took a flight around Malibu around point
dume and you go over there and you see
these massive estates just burnt to the
ground.
These gorgeous houses with the perfect
view on the bluff overlooking the ocean.
Gone huge lots,
you know,
$20,000,000 houses gone just burnt to
the ground and there's so many of them.
And then like one house standing there,
one house out of just random.
That's how it was in our neighborhood to
house caught fire,
but nothing near it.
Caught fire hose.
It's weird.
Yeah.
Some shit.
We'll fly through the air land on
someone's house and if you have like
pine needles or something on your roof
or a flammable roof,
just catches,
catches on fire.
Was it a campfire that started taking
part?
It's called Campfire.
Oh,
I don't think it was a campfire.
That was the name of the fire.
I don't think.
I don't.
I don't know what the fuck the cause of
that fire was.
Jamie CV.
You find that out.
Do you know what it is?
They've been trying to blame or blame
has been put on like different utility
companies and whatnot.
And they're,
they're not taking the blame or they can
prove that it wasn't them and wow,
it's been being passed around.
I don't know that anybody knows yet what
I've been looking at.
You know,
it's fucking crazy though,
man.
When,
uh,
I was in boulder,
there was a giant fire that broke out
that was a fireman accidentally started
a fire.
Yeah.
He had a fire pit in his backyard and
some fucking embers blew out of his fire
pit and started a giant fire and just
burn massive amounts of wild forest.
It's just gone.
Damn.
A fireman.
I imagine he must,
must've felt like shit.
It mean anybody start.
I mean,
just couldn't fucking imagine if it was
your fault that one of these things get
started.
Oh yeah.
The guilt.
I would.
I wouldn't be sleeping for weeks.
Decrease territory is northern
California.
Northern California got it way where we
got it bad down here,
worse than I've ever seen.
But they get it way worse in northern
California,
Northern California.
They lost a shitload of people died on
the highway.
That's what I see burned to death in
their cars.
You see those photos?
Yeah.
Fuck man.
A lot of this is because of,
you mean there's a lot of issues,
right?
There's the dry,
um,
you know,
the fact that dry climate,
the fact that climate change is
happening,
but also the fact that there is no small
fires like although those dead trees are
supposed to get knocked down by small
fires like controlled fires and those,
that doesn't really happen anymore.
We don't want small fires that can
possibly get out of hand.
And so you have these forests that are
oftentimes filled with dead trees right
next to live trees and a lot of dead
trees all over the place.
Wow.
So they're supposed to do,
that's like maintenance burning like the
small gallons
before.
There's May mean some people advocate
doing it for maintenance,
but in nature that's like a natural
thing.
Like the lightning would hit light
something shit on fire and the live
trees would probably survive and a lot
of the dead ones would burn to the
ground and we'd actually regenerate the
forest.
Yeah.
I mean the crazy thing is like you look
how fucking lush and green it looks out
here now,
but you would never imagine that just a
few months ago this was a raging
inferno.
It actually is good for the ground,
you know,
and all that
still smells like fire too right now.
Prices.
Yeah.
Every time it rains it's starting to get
a little bit better.
But does it freak you out when you see
fire now because of your accident?
Yeah,
it took a little while for us to have
pyro again.
Oh you never.
It was like we just got back together
and like this really,
really like killer,
like photographer had this idea to do
this photo shoot and they wanted us
holding like the watchman call it the
thing like the flares accent.
He got me to hold it for a second and I
was like,
oh bro,
I can't do this wrong photo shoot.
Like I'm sorry,
you know,
I know you have this vision,
but that's an insensitive vision.
Yeah.
And I.
Yeah,
yeah,
right.
That would have been a little bit more
fitting but.
And then and now we do pyro stuff on,
on stage and production.
It doesn't really bug me but I'm very
cautious around the house.
Like with my daughter,
she has like a straight iron plugged in
or for my son,
whatever lights a candle.
Like I'm so crazy about it,
which
are a little weird.
So I have to ask you this,
Tom.
Talk about Ufos all the time.
Well you know,
he's not in the band.
No,
I know,
but I always do that.
He always did.
We used to get loaded and just look out
the bus window and I used to do it with
him as like,
I don't know,
it's kind of a bonding experience.
It's like if you wanted to show me bow
and arrows,
whatever were on tour together,
I sit there and like,
you know,
check it out.
So with Tom,
that was his thing,
like fucking let's get high and look for
Ufo.
So he would just sit there and like
stare out the bus window,
look at Ufo or like he would even go as
far as when we're on tour,
like let's go and fucking look for
bigfoot.
But whatever it was,
you know,
and he would assemble a crew and they
would go do it.
Oh my God,
I never got me on one of those trips
because that was just to fairy tale for
me.
But um,
but I,
you know,
I'd do that.
And he was always,
it's really not something he just got
into from the day I fucking met him when
he was obsessed with Ufo and aliens and
was always very passionate about it to
the point where like I didn't know
enough to,
to have any kind of,
I guess like opinion on it.
I was just very open and,
and you know,
just took it all in,
but nothing has changed.
He's still,
the other day I talked to him,
he's like,
I'm on the way to the fucking White
House Bro.
And I don't ask any questions I like,
as you should be,
you know,
whatever.
Let's fucking go get a great response.
Yeah.
Good luck with that.
Wow,
that's crazy.
Yeah,
he was a trip man.
Having a conversation with him was very
strange because I'm,
a part of me was like skype putting me
on like what is happening is dead ass
just seemed like it.
And we would look at these videos that
were so clearly horseshit and he would
be like amazing.
Right?
And they're like,
what?
Like you think that that's an actual
Ufo?
Like that is the fakest fucking video.
I've ever seen in my life,
but he didn't see that at all,
but yeah,
in his mind he was seeing a real alien
spaceship.
Even on tour.
I'd be like,
walk in my room and be like,
what are you doing?
I'm like,
oh,
check this thing out.
I just made up whatever,
playing drums.
He'd be like,
dude,
fucking whatever.
George Bush just did you know,
he needs just coming at me with some
like politics.
He's been watching CNN or,
or like he's just,
he's always been obsessed with it,
so he's obsessed with all sorts of like
hidden things,
so not just Ufo
but big foot too.
Conspiracy theories,
politics,
everything.
Very,
very passionate about all those things.
Conspiracy theories and politics.
It's interesting how those things
go together because people are always
wondering like,
who the fuck is running things?
What's really going on?
What's happening behind the scenes?
Who's pulling the strings?
What is it all really mean?
You know?
Ah,
but the UFO thing,
it's like,
boy,
you gotta.
I mean,
I absolutely believe there could be
intelligent life out there,
but I haven't seen a fucking single
thing that makes me think that anybody's
got a picture
video.
Yeah.
I feel like it could,
it could be real.
I believe,
but I'm not,
I can't fucking.
I'm not dedicating my life to search for
it,
you know,
and I give it to a man to like honestly
to walk away from your fucking very
successful band to go do that shit.
Like I have nothing but respect for his
passion,
but it's like I couldn't do that.
That's insane.
Yeah.
It's like that just,
it really shows like he's,
you know,
he's very,
very passionate about it.
It will be saved up some money.
Yeah,
me too.
You know,
a survivor.
Survivorman Les Stroud.
Nah,
he's a,
you ever see that show?
A fucking great show.
He would.
Survivor man would go out into the woods
with a limited amount of things.
He would say like,
okay,
I've got this bucket,
I've got a fucking pocket knife and I
got a ball,
a ball of yarn and I'm going to survive
out here for seven days.
And in and he films the whole thing and
he'd be filming himself like eating
frogs and catching a squirrel and
finding edible plants and just living
out in the forest and oftentimes going
days and days without food.
And then he would have like a point
where he'd get rescued seven days in,
there would be a spot where they would
meet him.
Um,
he had an experience when he was in
Alaska a long time ago where he was
camping and he said he heard footsteps,
like big heavy footsteps.
And you heard some sound that sounded
like a gorilla,
like something like that.
And then it ran off.
And to this day he's convinced that that
was a big foot.
And so now he has survivor man bigfoot.
And he goes out into the woods and just
looks for evidence of sasquatch.
Well,
he should.
He needs to.
He needs,
they hit up.
Tom.
Tom pull up,
he'll go with.
And he would love that.
I'm sure he would.
Fuck.
He's trying to get me to go with them.
I'm like,
good luck.
I did.
I did it one time.
I went hunting for big foot for a
television show I did for Scifi.
I called Joe Rogan questions,
everything we went looking for bigfoot
and the more I talk to these big foot
folks that Maura was convinced,
none of these motherfuckers have ever
seen big flood.
There was one lady that I talked to,
one lady who just did not seem like a
liar and she was telling me that she saw
something in the woods and it was
standing up and it was tall,
like seven,
eight feet tall,
and she's like,
why is there a gorilla in the woods?
And then she's like,
oh my God,
that's pig foot.
And he said,
and it was the Pacific northwest outside
of Washington state or in Washington
state outside of Seattle,
and the woods are so dense up there that
if anything goes 10,
20 feet,
it's gone.
The problem with that is that there's
black bears up there in black bear,
sometimes standing up on two feet.
They do it all the time and if you saw a
blackfoot,
especially a black bear rather,
especially from a distance,
you would think it was a big gorilla.
It was standing up on two feet,
which they do do,
especially when they're trying to see
something.
They'll stand up and they'll even walk.
This is a lot of videos of them walking
on two feet and just never seen it.
That's crazy.
I could see a big 400 percent.
So I think,
I don't think that lady is
liar.
I just,
uh,
don't.
She might look,
it might be real.
There might be a few of them left.
There definitely was a thing called
gigantic [inaudible] that lived in Asia
and the thought is that it came across
the bering land bridge the same time
that native Americans came across from
Asia and that they came across and
because they lived in Asia and this,
this gigantic Pythius I think lived as
recently I think as 100,000 years ago.
I think the most recent fossils they
have of it,
which is human beings were alive back
then.
And this thing was a six or an eight to
10 foot tall bipedal hominid.
So it was a huge,
huge apelike creature.
So check this out.
This is a
look at this bear.
So the craziest shit ever.
Bears walking on two legs.
Look at him.
Wow.
Like if you saw that,
like totally like,
oh my God,
it's a fucking pig foot.
Especially if you believe the hype and
do your search for big foot out there.
Yes.
Yeah.
Or if you're on shrooms yet,
right?
I mean if you're walking,
if you're high on mushrooms,
you're like,
oh my God,
look at that thing.
He's like,
hey,
how you doing?
Oh,
he's got to hurt.
Right foot.
That's what that is.
You see his right foot or something
wrong with his right foot sometimes.
Yeah.
It looks like he's missing his front.
Paws says sometimes bears will fight
with each other.
One barrel.
Bite the bear's foot off.
Or he could have gotten shot or it could
have broke it off on something.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
He's missing a foot.
So he's.
He's walking around out Taylor gorilla.
But everybody else.
I was like,
when I'm talking to them,
they're like living in make believe
world.
Here's another one.
Walking around.
Look at him.
Wow.
That is weird man.
Those are big ass bears.
Big Ass bear Hillen.
On two feet,
I mean they look like fucking people,
man.
I think that is a big reason why they're
feeding them.
That is so crazy.
Where is that?
That doesn't seem like America.
South Korea is South Korea.
Wow.
Oh the.
So that's one of those wildlife parks
where the animals are all.
And you're in a car.
Yeah,
that's like fake wildlife.
I mean wildlife,
but not really wild.
Have you ever see that video where the
lady was in China and they were in one
of those parks and she got in a fight
with her boyfriend.
So she got out of the car and she got
killed by a tiger.
No,
she actually,
she didn't get killed.
Her mom got killed.
She's more fucked up because her mom
came out to rescue her.
She got snatched by the tiger and then
her mom watch this shit.
This is crazy.
On another video of it,
she's like,
fuck you.
I'm fucking walk in.
And they're like,
hey listen,
bitch,
get back in the fucking car.
There's tigers out here.
And she's like,
no,
fuck you and fuck him and fuck you.
And the tiger.
Just grabs her,
snatches her out.
So the guy runs out and then the mom
runs out and apparently the mom got
killed.
Two.
Here comes the mom.
That lady wound up dying.
Wow.
Yeah.
And there was a park ranger like shit.
When you get snatched up by a 600 pound
cat,
she about that fucking dude in Colorado
today.
He killed a mountain lion with his bare
hands.
He smothered to death,
jacked him while he was jogging.
He was running on the trails.
The mountain lion grabbed him from
behind.
You getting a struggle with is 80 pound
cat and wound up suffocating it.
I guess fucking bad ass jog or just I
want to know the fuck bar is net.
Fuck you.
Fuck.
It would have to be like Derrick Lewis
or someone you know like.
So I can't picture anyone else being
able to do that.
Maybe is a Jujitsu guy.
We see him.
I've seen him when my kids were really
young in Calabasas where I live,
I saw one like just pacing back and
forth and my back fence.
Jesus,
they're out here man.
They're out here.
And then we see coyotes and deer all the
time.
But mountain lions,
that's next level.
Scary.
Yeah.
A friend of mine just sent me a message
this morning when I was.
When I posted that thing on instagram
about that guy that killed it and he
said he was running on this fire road
and he realized he like,
felt weird and looked over and 20 feet
away from him was a big cat right above
him on this Ridge,
20 feet.
So that's basically us to that wall.
Big Cat just look at and he said he
waved his arms to look bigger and think
just walked away like a.
I carry a knife when I run,
I carry a fucking half phase blades has
got to like a loop.
You could stick your thumb into it so it
stays in your hand and people are like,
why are you running with a knife?
What the fuck he doing?
Like you don't need it until you do.
And when you do you want to have it.
Didn't someone get attacked by a coyote
and hidden hills?
Like running to the story about that.
But I mean,
I ran in my neighborhood before and it
to coyotes ran right past me and they
usually don't mess with like humans,
you know.
Well we had a problem with them killing
chickens because chickens in my yard,
I've lost a bunch of chickens to.
Coyotes were.
They were,
they were on top of the chicken
coop,
poem tiles off of it.
They're creepy little fuckers man,
but they're little,
you know,
these are like 35,
45 pounds.
They're not very big,
but they're creepy and some about their
little wolves and they're looking at you
and they're trying to figure out a way
like what can they eat,
what can't the.
They're out there scraping,
scraping and grinding.
They're sneaky.
Like
sure.
Like I saw one of my friends,
a dear friend of mine,
lost both of his dogs to coyotes and he
had,
I think he had like surveillance of it
and one is in the yard and he's playing
dead.
And then his dogs approach what they
think is dead.
And then basically like his home,
he comes out of nowhere and attacks and
a both.
And the one that's playing dead attacks
and both of his dogs were a rap.
How big dogs?
Small.
I mean there were smaller dogs,
but now he has like big German shepherds
and he's,
you know,
he's kind of like got bigger dogs now.
But it was really sad,
man.
It is a very tactical,
like very,
very crazy.
Yeah.
They,
they figure out some way to work and
cooperate together without
communicating.
It's very interesting.
Like if it wasn't so sad that they're
killing someone's pat,
it's,
it's really kind of fascinating that
they're so smart that they would play
dead.
There was a guy that used to work at
this pet store that I go to and he also
worked in a veterinary center,
a medical place,
and a pit bull came in.
Big One of those big Jack pitbulls just
covered and cuts,
cuts all over its body.
And uh,
the owner was,
they asked the owner like,
what the fuck happened?
He goes,
I don't know.
I came home and he's covered in cots.
I really have no idea what happened to
them.
So they stitched the dog up like
hundreds of stitches all over the dog's
body.
Then he takes a walk outside of his
house and he follows his dog's blood and
he goes up into the hills near his house
and he finds nine dead coyotes.
Wow.
That pit pole was
apparently tear and he said it looked
like Vietnam.
It looked like a fucking like saving
private Ryan just ripped apart coyotes.
Nine of them.
This motherfucker just went mall and
they must have been so bummed out to
like this dog.
Yeah,
there's nine of us.
We're good.
We got this guy here and then you see
this fucking fire hydrant head.
Just
that doesn't feel pain.
They've engineered those things.
Like there's some pit bulls.
This pit bull.
If you go on Instagram,
I think it's.
I am the hulk.
That's the name of the.
It's a 200 pound pit bull.
Like they've gotten them to 200 pounds.
Now.
It's the most preposterous thing you've
ever seen your life it looks like.
Like,
like Brock Lesnar,
if it was a pit bull,
it's like it doesn't even make any
sense.
You look at it like a pit bull used to
be like a 35 pound dog.
These to be small.
Look at that thing.
Yeah.
Are.
Imagine if a coyote saw that.
Fuck.
Yeah,
those bull Max.
This is fucking scary too.
Oh
yeah.
I had a master if he passed away
recently.
I was 13 years old.
We had to put him down and it was really
sad.
He was.
He was a great dog.
Mastiffs are so sweet.
Like look at the size of that fucking
dog,
man.
Fuck.
Just go to just crazy 200 pound pit
bull.
It's just so crazy that they make them
that big now.
Like 100 pound pit bull used to be a
bit.
I had a 90 pound one.
It was a big dog and it was like wow,
that's a big pit bull.
And like as a big pit bull,
this dogs 110 pounds bigger.
Maybe it doesn't even make any sense.
So fucking tank.
Yeah,
but that.
That's one of my favorite coyote death,
death stories.
This guy going up into the hills and
find all these dead coyote just laying
in a pile.
They try to ambush them.
When they would do,
they try to get one to come out and try
to get chased and then the one would run
and then the other ones would jump it.
There's like a gang straight up.
That's crazy that they think like that
though.
The fact that they have actually have
strategies,
they're savages,
you know?
Well that's the downside of living in
the suburbs,
you know,
the upside is you get a nice yard and
he'd get a little view and yeah.
I love getting away from the city or
like,
you know,
it's like studio or just chaos,
whatever.
Just going home and being home.
Yeah,
me too.
Nice.
Do you ever keep,
do you keep a place up in big bear
anywhere?
I don't go up there.
I don't really like traveling really?
Nah,
after my accident I fucking hate
traveling.
Like I'll go on tour but I won't even
look at an itinerary before I go on
tour.
I just Kinda like just tell me where to
go.
I'll be up.
I'll be where I need to be,
but yeah,
like I don't want to and I don't fly,
you know,
I haven't flown since my accident.
So.
Wow.
So all your touring you do is by bus,
by bus and then I'll take the Queen Mary
two to Europe.
But
do you take a boat to Europe?
Yeah.
Manager of your boat.
Sunk.
Know on a fucking float,
Raf going mother fucker.
Yeah,
trust me.
But you know what?
I'd rather be on the fucking raft then
fucking plummeting into the ocean at 100
miles per hour or whatever.
Yeah.
I feel you.
I'm to like take Guna for like quick
getaways,
like you know,
just chill out with the family.
So if you guys have a Gig in New York
City,
you have to start your journey five days
early.
Yeah.
Wow.
But it's cool.
The kids and I get to see a lot of stuff
we don't normally see.
Yeah.
But I got to really think about it like,
like that fucking fire festival if they
had booked us on and I was like,
I'm so glad because I would have had to
drive five or six days,
you know,
to uh,
Florida to Fort Lauderdale,
then get in a boat and then get over to
the bomb as.
So thank God man.
Because I was,
I was literally on my way there.
Wow.
So when you do that,
do you actually drive yourself or do you
have someone drive?
You know,
I'd be white knuckling driving the tour
bus if you driven a fucking scary man
while you driving like this.
I've done it like wow.
Like when I was 19 or 20,
when I was on a tour,
the driver let me drive and it was the
scariest fucking thing.
I was like,
take the fucking wheel man.
This is so like a white knuckling,
like just being in control,
being responsible over that big of a
bus.
And all of my homeys are all your
friends are sleeping in it.
Oh.
So it's like,
oh gosh man,
I give it bus drivers or that's a hard
fucking job and a drive for,
you know,
I think we usually do eight to 10 hour
days a day bus.
It's a long time.
It is a long time.
So it's quite a drive.
But in,
you know,
they have to stay awake and maintain
their focus and I don't know about you
but when I see those white lines to
something about that,
it's not good for me.
I start non.
Yeah.
It's like hypnotizing.
It is hypnotized.
You can do like two or three hours and
I'm cool.
I don't exactly know.
San Diego is about as far as I want to
drive.
Yeah.
They're built different and I know fuck,
you know,
they say it's way more dangerous to be
on the road in a bus or on a car than
being in a plane.
But um,
I don't know,
one day I always say like,
my kids want to fly one day,
maybe I'll be down.
But the thought of me leaving to go play
some show or do something cool and
something happening while they're at
home like fucks me up.
So I don't really do it.
I know what you mean.
I can only imagine.
I mean,
I don't think anybody's ever going to be
able to understand what you've gone
through with that kind of an ordeal.
That plane crash where your friends died
and the pilots are dead and you managed
to get out alive but almost lost your
foot and burned half your body plus.
Yeah.
No fuck man.
It's crippling.
But I try not to let it be too much of a
handicap for traveling,
but seemed like you seem like you got to
work around.
You figured it out.
Yeah.
But Australia can go fuck itself.
Oh,
I wish I could go.
I said I love Australia.
I love Japan.
Do you guys go there for UFC fights?
Yeah.
Have been fucking love it.
They did the UFC in Tokyo once.
It was great.
I honestly wanted to move there.
Really?
Yeah.
I loved it so much.
David Lee Roth moved there for a while.
Yeah,
he,
he moved there to take sword fighting
classes.
Fuck yeah.
Moved down with his dog,
got an apartment.
He is the.
Have you ever talked to him?
Now?
He is one of the trippiest fucking God.
I just got a message really recently
that he wanted to talk to me and so they
gave me a phone number for him.
I sent him a text message and never
heard back.
So like I might have to call them like,
I don't know,
I don't want to miss it out.
So if Dave,
if you're listening.
I tried twice but he said he wanted to
get ahold of me for something and they
gave him a number.
They gave me a number to get ahold of
him,
but he's one of the more interesting
people I've ever talked to in my life.
Worked as an emt for a while when he,
he'd just gotten out of Van Halen.
Really?
Yes,
like an actual emt,
like helping people like in New York and
people be like,
what are you fucking David Lee Roth?
And be like,
Hey,
we're getting in the ambulance,
like tv,
keep it together.
They like strapped to a Gurney when
there had accidents and shit and fucking
date.
You imagine you get in a car accident
and fucking David Lee Roth is going to
help you.
You're like,
what?
What am I?
I'm asked to be dead.
This isn't real life magic.
Fucking David Lee Roth.
So that's fine.
But that's legendary.
I love that.
I love.
He's a trip.
Yeah,
that'd be a great interview.
Move to Japan with his dog.
Just just hung out.
There I go.
What are you doing?
He's like taking Kendo lessons.
It's taking sword fighting lessons from
a Japanese master.
Whoa.
So everyday be take,
taking fucking Kendo sick.
He's uh,
he's the real deal,
man.
He's a real deal.
Like a real eccentric but a really
friendly,
really interesting guy.
Yeah.
Well that's awesome.
I love when someone is like that,
you know,
like your friend that hasn't taught for
22 years.
I love shit like that.
You don't hear about that?
No.
Or someone that'll stopping and van
Halen to go fuck with sorts.
Aliens.
Yeah.
It goes,
fucks with all.
Do to think they're really bringing him
to the Pentagon and shit like that.
I don't know because he said that like,
I have no clue and I had watched a
little bit of your podcast where you
were like,
you sent me a text message,
can you,
you know,
but I feel like he's made himself
readily available to do that shit.
You know,
like,
I don't know.
It's a,
it's I,
I sit and scratch my head and go.
I don't know.
I don't know either.
I just fucking.
He's such a talented talented due to
manny's like such a good songwriter.
Yeah.
He.
Well,
he certainly is certainly a very
talented guy.
It's just so interesting that that's his
main point of focus.
Yeah.
I would think that if,
if aliens were real,
trump would've told us.
I really do believe that.
Yeah.
That guy is,
he's such a fucking loose cannon.
He became the president.
Like maybe they hid it from him or his
fucking chaotic is shit is right now.
It was some,
I don't know,
something would slip.
You know,
I,
yeah.
I would think that if they told him,
if they brought him a dose of two
things,
I would want to know who killed JFK.
Those are two things I'd want to know if
I became the president and our aliens.
Real.
What do you got?
Motherfucker?
What are you going?
I go to the top generals.
I bet.
Look,
I'm going to defer to you guys.
I'm not a military expert.
Okay.
I mean,
I don't want war,
but uh,
I want you guys to have support.
I got full respect.
Tell me about the elite.
What do you got?
What's it trump orders?
Establishment of space for.
He did that.
That's right.
The space fourth,
but that's because there's actually a
military strategy because they're
concerned that as technology improves,
Russians are going to be in space and
we're going to be in space or war.
Fight off the aliens.
Right?
Like will Smith Type Shit?
Yeah.
Look at him.
Mike pence is behind them going.
Jesus was going to say almost.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
But if I became president and I never
will,
but if I did,
those are the two things that I'd want
to know who killed jfk and where the
fucking aliens.
Do you think they know?
Do you think they know anything more
than regular people?
Because you've got to feel like they
come in every four years.
Someone would open their mouth.
Somebody knows.
Somebody knows
he's an alien.
He's not going to rat on his friends.
Right.
If you drive that car,
I'll give you the cake.
Just take it for a tour or just take it
for a spin out of here.
I will.
That fucking tests will make you believe
in aliens.
It doesn't even make sense.
It does not make sense.
I feel like I'm driving a computer when
I'm in a tesla.
It's like every car other than that
seems stupid.
So the first one you've had.
Yes.
You're just completely in love with it.
Sold.
I drove one.
There was a rental car company that was
sponsoring the podcast and it was like
a,
like uber for rental cars.
They would drop off a rental car and
they would.
Do you remember the name of that
company?
I don't know if they're around anymore.
Anyway,
I said,
yeah,
I want to try a tesla,
and I drove it.
I was like,
this is kind of interesting,
but this was years ago,
like maybe five years ago.
Was that four years ago?
Five years ago it wasn't as impressive,
but now I got the model s p 100 d,
this is what he told me to get.
So I said,
all right,
I'll get it.
I drove that thing.
The moment I drove it,
the very first,
the first couple of feet,
like what is happening here?
Like why is this going so fast?
It doesn't make sense.
It's effortless.
Effortless.
Like every other car on the road has to
accelerate.
It's like,
man man,
this shit.
He just,
it's instantaneously going 60 miles an
hour.
I mean,
it just feels like it's,
it's happening in like blink,
blink,
60.
Yeah.
And fucking smooth and just.
You can't hear anything.
I don't hear anything.
It handles great.
It's quiet,
it's shit.
It's comfortable.
Yeah.
I'm fucked because dude,
I'm a gear head.
I'm like,
you,
I know you saw that blazer.
Yeah.
Do.
That's dope.
Yeah.
I tried building like my icon version of
a blazer.
You know,
who built that for you?
Uh,
his name was del Moe.
He was over here in the valley so he did
the ls swap and then I had another buddy
of mine painted and then I've just kind
of like ground up like suspension.
But I feel like I should have replaced
the chassis and done everything like
that if I wanted it to be like a true
icon,
but it's a bad fucking truck look and
truck.
There it is.
That's so sick.
It's so,
you know,
icons done some blazers.
Yeah,
I saw when they did afterwards.
Oh,
so you have,
it's a full convertible.
No hard top God damn.
That looks good dude.
Yeah,
I put a soft top on it,
like a bikini top,
but summertime I just take it all off
but I have roll a roll cage too.
Sick.
I love it.
I love the lowered ones too,
like the slanted ones if so.
Nice.
That's so nasty,
man.
Is that the color you have?
Like a matte,
it's such a cool matt like charcoal,
Mercedes Gray.
God,
that looks good.
Yeah,
it almost pops wheelies.
It's so fucking strong is so much
horsepower.
Which engine they put in there?
An ls three.
Oh,
okay.
What is,
how many horsepower is that?
I think I'm at like 700.
So ridiculous.
But besides that,
you know,
I had like,
I had like 16 old schools.
I've actually,
so you're really actually fell out of
love with them.
It's kind of weird or I think I've spent
like my time with them and I'm ready to
like separate from them and move on and
maybe like get other stuff or like,
I don't know,
I feel like it was a moment in time
though.
I was like Kinda like Hoodrich in a
sense where I'm putting all my money
into cars.
Like before I ever bought a house I had
like four caddies,
you know,
and I was living in like a two story
house,
a two bedroom house with a bunch of
friends.
But um,
to that old red one behind you is dope.
What is that?
I still have that 53 chevy truck.
Oh,
that looks cool.
Icon.
Does some of those two.
You ever see the master masters?
So he's got one for sale right now.
I saw it.
Yeah.
Somebody,
uh,
had one built and then just never drove
it.
And he's selling it is nasty dude.
I go over there and window shop all
that.
Have you met him?
Johnson were cool.
He's very cool.
He drove me there.
This mass.
That one's available right now.
Look at that fucking thing.
He drove me in one of those and was like
hitting corners at 70.
Like I fucking,
I almost lost my breath.
I was like,
this motherfucker is crazy,
but they really do perform their fucking
cars.
Even my bronco even though it's so high,
so high off the ground,
you would think that thing handles like
shit and handles really good for,
for something like that.
Is it like stock how it comes from icon?
Like that same height or did you do
anything to Istock?
Yeah,
he just does them all that way.
And uh,
I was originally going to get an f made
from him and I went there and I saw the
Bronco and person with that matte silver
and I was like,
Holy Shit.
Did I go scrap the fucking F J we need
to get this going.
So did you,
did you do the whole build out like you
how?
How long did it take?
Well it was on w you're on a waiting
list for a long time.
And then I think the build took close to
a year.
It's like close to a year.
Patient get me too far.
But the key is like have it in the
thing,
just forget about it because then time
goes by.
Do you drive it a lot?
All the time.
I dropped to the comedy store like two
or three nights a week,
but since I got the Tesla I'm telling
you man,
it really ruined me.
It's ruined me.
I'm a gearhead yeah.
Like old school.
Cause I have a 65 corvette with an ls.
[inaudible] supercharged drive that all
the time side pipe,
silver shape.
I love it.
But it seems so dumb.
It seems so don wants to drive a tesla.
Wow.
It's effortless,
dude.
It just goes shit.
It's like you're on fast forward.
I need to check it out.
Everybody else is living in the past.
Yeah.
Like maybe last year I used to have a,
um,
the wraith like the Rolls Royce.
That's a sick car.
Bad car?
Yeah.
Do you have the ceiling with all the
lights?
Looks like space.
It was so sick.
But my buddy,
my buddy John said,
hey,
let's swap cars at wherever we were
driving.
So I did.
And I was,
I was,
I was really impressed.
It was,
it fucking,
it was really,
really fast.
Which one did he have?
Did he have the 100 day?
I imagine it's the one before the one
you're talking about because it was a
couple of years ago.
Those were fast.
Yeah.
But it was still impressive.
You know,
those were fast.
They're still fast,
but this one is fucking stupid.
Yeah.
It doesn't make sense.
It's like you,
it's like you're defying what you think
a thing can do and it has that big
fucking screen where it has all your
information.
Yeah,
yeah.
They're dope.
He's a.
he's definitely a legend man.
Elon Musk.
He's not as blow torch to like,
he's fucking.
He lit that fucking thing up in the
hallway out here.
No.
Yeah,
I thought I was going to burn the
building.
I haven't even lit mine.
I'm so afraid of my sons.
Of course.
Animal.
I don't want him to know how to turn it
on.
Yeah.
He gave it to me.
Put the fucking fuel in it and
everything.
I was learning.
All right,
thanks.
Crazy.
Like comes bearing gifts.
How many people give you a blowgun blow
torch?
Torch con.
Which called.
It's not a blow torch,
right?
No.
What does he call it?
It's not a.
it's not a bullet or not a blow torch.
Is that what it's called?
That believe so.
Yeah.
Whatever it is,
there's a crazy picture online that we
put up of him shooting that fucking
thing out in the hallway and you're
like,
you can't tell them no.
You know,
like no one tells them no,
he's got security around them and all
these fucking,
all these mercenaries with guns.
No one saying,
hey,
he rose hard,
dude,
he's the Elon Musk.
It's worth billions.
However,
where it goes.
I mean he's.
He's got to have security everywhere.
Guys come before him and case everything
out.
Yeah,
look at him.
What did I conic photo
with the Freak party sign above his
head.
It's almost like we planned it and
Steven Tyler,
that Steven Tyler's mugshot and the
background
crazy man he takes from your guys'
interview to where he's just like
fucking stone.
Be Honest.
So great.
I don't think he got stoned.
I don't think he really inhaled.
He took like a tiny puff.
I think he puffed it like a cigar
smokes.
We didn't inhale.
He drinks.
We drank.
That's what was interesting about that.
The blowback or the backlash is that we
drank for two hours before we even
busted out the weed,
but the weed was like,
what are they doing?
God takes one hit of weed.
What are they doing?
And then it went crazy and stock
plummeted six percent,
but it went back up to nine percent
smoke before you drink.
Right.
I think you get really fucked up if you
don't smoke a lot and you smoke after
you've been drinking.
Really?
It's a wrap.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I don't know.
He never seen it.
I don't think it affected him.
He was like,
well,
he's so.
His brain is wired so different.
You know what his brain is like.
It's like you ever see like,
okay,
no disrespect to Pete Holmes,
but you know Pete Holmes,
the comedian,
like look at his body and then look at
Usain bolt's.
That's how I feel like,
like the way if they had a race,
that's how I feel like with my brain in
the room with Elan's brain,
I was like,
well,
these are barely the same thing.
Keep up man.
Like you.
You've had some crazy guests that are
talking about atoms and fucking the
universe and whatever else,
and you're always like,
you.
You keep up with everybody.
It's an illusion to memorize things.
Yeah.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking
about.
They know.
They understand the actual concepts.
You know?
I might be able to repeat things that
I've learned in red,
but I don't know what the fuck I'm
really talking about.
They know what the fuck they're like,
you know what I'm saying?
It's like if someone never did Jujitsu
before and they want to talk about
choking someone out a triangle and I
hear them say and I'm like,
okay,
Yay.
That's how you do it.
But they don't really know how to do it.
You know what I'm saying?
But then if you're talking to hoists
Gracie,
he tells you how to choke someone out
with a triangle like this.
Motherfucker did it.
He knows how to do it.
He does it all the time.
It's a different conversation,
you know?
So that's the difference.
Like me,
I'm like a spectator talking to these
geniuses,
but I just trying to pull information
out of them.
I'm just trying to get them to talk,
you know,
I just try to know a little bit about
what they're talking about.
The guys that were on a,
I don't know,
what was it last week,
the guys that we're talking about like
longevity,
like living.
Yeah,
Davidson,
Clara.
That was pretty crazy.
Fascinating.
Yeah.
This.
I'm glad there's people like that out
there.
I think within the next 15 to 20 years,
people are going to start going back in
aging like legitimately they're going to
be able to not just slow down aging,
but we're going to see like 60 year old
ladies are hot as fuck.
We're going to see 60 year old ladies
looked at 32.
I really believe that I do to coming
around the corner.
Especially that guy who's talking about
that diabetic medicine that he takes
metformin.
Yeah.
But apparently,
um,
that stuff has negative impacts on
athletic performance.
It's one of the things that I was
curious about when,
when he discussed it and Dr Rhonda
Patrick sent me something on it and Ben
Greenfield actually brought it up on the
podcast.
We did a couple of days afterwards.
Uh,
yeah.
It's,
um,
I don't,
it's,
it's probably good for longevity but not
good for athletic performance,
which is a,
I'm not willing to make that sacrifice
and he's probably not really concerned
with athletic performance.
No,
no.
He barely worked out and he wasn't into
working out hard either.
Was like his,
his deals,
like just maintain a little bit of
exercise,
just kind of keep the blood moving.
But a lot of those guys that are these
super genius sort of longevity experts,
they're just interested in how you can
slow the clock down as much as possible.
And then there's other people like Ben
Greenfield or like I'm Rhonda Patrick,
they're more interested in performance.
Like what is,
what's the thing for you in terms of,
for your mental performance,
physical performance.
I'm more in line with that,
but um,
but I'm also,
I want to know what these guys are
working on.
The Davidson Claire's of the world
because he's at the top of the,
you know,
the tip of the spear when it comes to
longevity and,
and gene editing and you know,
what they're talking about is being able
to inject certain what certain genes are
bacteria that carry genes.
It's going to fix it.
Eyesight.
Wow.
Yeah.
Crazy.
Like people that are blind are going to
be able to see again,
like,
yeah,
they're going to be able to do some mad,
mad shit as long as human beings don't.
We don't figure out.
I mean we don't nuke ourselves or fuck
the world to a point where,
you know,
scientific research halts.
If these guys can keep going,
if we can make it to the next 50 years,
people are probably going to live to be
300 years old.
Wow.
Yeah.
Nuts,
man.
I love it.
How fucking smart people are going to be
at the 300.
I mean,
think about how smart you are compared
to when you were 20.
I was a dummy.
So done.
I'm so dumb.
I'm amazed.
I'm still here.
Like I stop and think about how I used
to drive.
I'll say,
oh,
now you have old schools.
Do you have hot rods?
You have any hot rods?
Not Pretty much like Sullivan though,
like old schools.
Those are safer at a couple of impalas.
I just got rid of two of my impalas and
I have like a 53 caddy.
I still have.
I have a 64,
60 5:53 truck in a 41 caddy 41 cat.
It's nice man.
It's really fucking Nice.
But it's like a three speed,
you know what I mean?
Like it's like it's,
you know.
No,
I'm old school power steering.
It's like you gotta know how to drive.
So yeah,
I still have a couple that I'm holding
onto but I really,
we're steering.
Did steering wheel must be giants.
Gigantic.
It's so sketchy to,
to drive.
But yeah,
I'm going to bring,
I'm going to bring a couple out.
I have a um,
I have a festival that happens in March
called music that's like tattoos,
music and cars.
So I bring a couple of them out there.
Where's that?
At?
Orange County fairgrounds.
Oh,
all right.
Yeah.
Nice.
So,
but yeah,
but I'm slowly.
I really just,
I don't know.
I want a simpler life man.
I want to be able to get in a car and
not worry about it.
Fucking breaks down and I can get to
point a to point b with how busy I am.
I don't know.
Do it.
Stay the fuck away from that.
Tesla.
Yeah.
I'm telling you it'll ruin you.
Oh yeah,
there she is.
So that's yours.
Wow,
that's beautiful.
What a car.
What?
I mean,
what a like a,
not just a car but of window into time.
Yeah,
that's history.
I mean back in 1941.
That's what people drove,
man.
That was the shit back then.
People tooling around Manhattan and one
of those.
Yeah.
I love seeing those,
you know,
the movies that take place during those
timers and they find all those classics.
So cool.
You know,
it was great.
The more recent version of the great
gatsby with Leonardo Dicaprio when they
drove those cars,
but it was a weird movie because they
made those cars almost like modern.
It's very strange.
That's how Romeo and Juliet was two.
The one with the one with Leonardo.
You know what I'm talking about.
Did you notice that all the guns in
there were super ill cars,
sick.
They do some futuristic.
Yeah.
Some weird interpretation.
Yeah,
a time period.
Correct,
right.
Yeah.
So that time period.
Correct.
But when he drove that car,
it drove like no fucking car.
Like cvs find a scene where he actually
drove the car because it sounded like it
was supercharged and it's flying and
it's handling well,
but it's all like cartoonish.
Almost like everything.
The scenes or like when they're driving
these cars,
they're nothing like those cars were
back then.
Oh yeah.
Because they don't move like that.
Especially in the road.
Yeah.
Unless you do like an ls swap and you
read everything.
Like when they're on the road,
like these fucking cars didn't drive
like that man.
They didn't.
They'd have skinny ass bullshit tires.
They barely could break.
You hit the brakes.
It took forever to slow down.
That was a great movie though.
Yeah,
those are sick.
Yeah.
See,
they're all going sideways around
corners and shit.
Nobody did that back then.
It was weird.
Yeah.
It's weird how they do that with movies
where they have this like they're having
a race.
We're racing.
I mean with that electric car outside
will follow by these motherfuckers show.
The problem with those,
those Teslas is that once you get in one
other cars just seem kind of dumb.
They seem kind of old.
Oh,
I bet.
I feel like it's,
you're stepping into the future when you
drive those.
Anything else wouldn't seem even up to
date,
you know,
but there's something about cars like
you're 41 cadillac that have a theme to
them that you're never going to get from
a new car.
And you know,
what's cool about those is like when
you're in those,
you're not concerned with whatever's on
the radio or talking on the phone or I
don't know,
you're into just your content with just
hearing the car and driving.
You know,
driving is fun.
Yeah.
Whereas like if you're just in 2019
chevy truck,
you're not going to feel like that,
you know,
you take it that far back.
Just the smell of them.
Everything.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a vibe and it's just.
I don't know.
You can't compare it to anything.
Yeah.
When I bought my 65 corvette,
the first thing I do is pull the radio
gear.
That outta here.
I don't want to hear that radio is
unnecessarily.
Yeah,
I want to have those side pipes in the
wind,
but it's going to be a thing of the
past.
Man.
I really firmly believe that now after
driving this car,
I think 50 years from now those things
are going to be.
It's going to be like seeing some guy
drive by on a model.
T engines are going to be a thing of the
past.
It's probably better for the environment
anyway.
Oh,
for sure.
Anyway,
I think that's it.
Let's wrap this up.
Dope Dude.
Thank you so much.
I was really glad we got together,
man.
It was great.
Very cool talking to you.
Awesome.
Likewise.
Um,
social media.
Your instagram is just Travis Barker
Barker and use twitter as well or just
he asked St Charles Barker.
Beautiful.
Thanks brother.
Really appreciate it,
man.
It was fun.